et pour conclure que de toute façon on
aura besoin de la science mais tout ne
peut pas reposer sur la science voilà
lisez regard lisez l'hémicycle merci
beaucoup fait du pad pad merci beaucoup
Catherine tricot merci beaucoup et merci
Steve nous on se retrouve demain
prochain rendez-vous sur l'antenne à 15h
la séance de question d'actualité au
Gouvernement et puis à partir de 16h30
vous suivrez en direct l'examen du
projet de loi immigration très bonne
journée à
demain la presse quotidienne régionale
et les télévisions locales ont présenté
le club des
[Musique]
territoires NJ acteur engagé dans la
transition zé carbone des régions vous a
présenté le club des
[Musique]
territoires voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publsenat.fr
[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver on est ensemble comme tous les
jours pendant 1 heure et dem on fait le
point sur l'actualité près de chez
[Musique]
vous bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue
dans un monde en doc
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour de nouveau numéos de sport et
C amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous êtes
sur le plateau dès maintenant l'émission
qui revient avec plaisir avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le
principe bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à
tous Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de de reportage de
[Musique]
chronique
bonjour bonjour à tous ravi de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour le
rendez-vous du mercredi au Sénat j'ai
nommé les questions au Gouvernement on
est ensemble jusqu'à 15h heure à
laquelle nous irons en séance pour
suivre la séance de questions
d'interpellation des sénateurs au
ministres avec les commentaires avec les
réactions grâce à notre équipe de
journalistes en direct du Sénat avec
nous Alexandre Poussard salle des
conférences bonjour Alexandre bonjour th
avec vous toutes les réactions
politiques effectivement Tam et on
parlera du projet de loi immigration qui
est examiné à 7ette semaine au Sénat et
du fameux article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension
article qui sème la discorde mais ça y
est hier les sénateurs les républicains
et les sénateurs centristes qui
composent la majorité au Sénat sont
tombés d'accord sur une nouvelle
récriture de cette disposition avec un
durcissement des règles pour régulariser
et on en parlera juste après cette
séance de question d'actualité vers
16h15 je serai avec Breno rotillot le
président du groupe LR au Sénat Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe
centriste et puis je demanderai
également son avis au ministre du
Travail Olivier du sopt sur cette
nouvelle rédaction de ce dispositif de
régularisation merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre également avec nous dans
l'émicycle Audrey vetaz cette semaine
Audrey quels sont les thèmes marquants
de cette séance cet après-midi et bien
Tam deux thèmes forts se détachent
aujourd'hui le premier c'est
l'immigration en plein examen du projet
de loi sur le sujet le second c'est la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme alors
qu'une grande marche civique est
organisée dimanche à l'initiative du
président du Sénat et de la présidente
de l'Assemblée merci merci à tous les
deux et à tout à l'heure dans une
demi-heure deux éditorialistes sur ce
plateau Catherine tricot de regard et
Albert zénou du Figaro et nous
reviendrons justement sur l'organisation
dimanche de cette grande marche contre
l'antisémitisme à l'initiative de Gérard
Larcher et de y Bron
pivé
[Musique]
mais d'abord le projet de loi
immigration au Sénat le compromis trouvé
par le groupe LR et ses alliés
centristes autour de l'article 3 cet
article qui prévoyait la régularisation
des étrangers travaillant dans des
métiers en tension et qui étaient la
pomme de discord du texte cet article
est donc supprimé mais un compromis a
été trouvé pour que cette mesure figure
tout de même dans le texte Cécile Sixou
fumée blanche au Sénat après plusieurs
semaines de désaccord
lesrcentristes ont trouvé un deal sur le
fameux article 3 il prévoit la
régularisation des S papiers dans les
métiers en tenstion c'était une ligne
rouge pour les LR ils ont obtenu sa
suppression comme l'annonce bruneo
retaillot dans un communiqué diffusé
hier soir la majorité s'est accordé sur
la suppression des articles 3 et 4 du
projet de loi immigration il était en
effet inacceptable de créer un droit
opposable travailleurs clandestin
d'obtenir automatiquement un titre de
séjour si les LR ont obtenu gain de
cause pour un retrait il reste
symbolique car sur le fond des mesures
similaires seront intégrées au texte
dans un nouvel article la différence
l'accord de ces titres de séjour dans
les métiers en tension sera faite à
l'appréciation des préfets ils jugeront
en fonction de l'intégration du
comportement et du respect des valeurs
républicaines des demandeurs ce qui est
introduit n'est finalement que
explicitation d'un chapitre qui existe
déjà dans le droit des étrangers
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour que
nous fixons dans des condition
extrêmement restrictive donc on ne
retrouve pas l'article 3 différemment on
retrouve un sujet mais qui est un sujet
qui existe dans le droit des étrangers
et qui encore une fois est déjà traité
dans le droit des étrangers les
centristes favorables à une version plus
souple ont préféré trouver un compromis
avec leslr plutôt que de voir le texte
rejeté au Sénat c'est une ré nouvelle
qui est proposée au sénateurs qui sera
proposée dans la journée et qui sera
sans doute adoptée par le Sénat et qui
donc nous permet de sortir de cette
espèce d'impass dans laquelle on se
retrouva une impasse politique et qui
permet de construire quelque chose qui
soit dans le consensus de la majorité
sénatoriale et qui soit acceptable par
le
gouvernement l'examen de l'article 3
initialement reporté par la majorité au
Sénat pour se laisser du temps sera
finalement examiné en séance cet
après-midi grâce à cet accord le débat
en séance reprend son cours normal et
sur ce plateau j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir Dominique Estrosi Sasson
bonjour bonjour sénatrice les
républicains des Alpes Maritimes
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques à côté de vous François
patria bonjour sénateur de la Côte d'Or
et président du groupe des sénateurs
Renaissance le groupe RDPI ici au Sénat
également sur ce plateau Jérôme Durin
bonjour bonjour sénateur socialiste de
la son et Loire et vice-président de la
commission des lois Dominique estr
Sasson vous obtenez donc la suppression
des articles 3 et 4 le premier prévoyait
la régularisation des travailleurs sans
papi dans les métiers en tension le
second l'accès immédiat au marché du
travail pour le demandeur d'asile est-ce
que vous êtes entièrement satisfaite à
ce stade des discussions d'abord la
suppression des articles 3 et 4 ça fait
depuis le début de l'examen du texte et
même avant que le groupe les
républicains la demande donc nous
n'avons pas changé d'avis mais bien
évidemment nous avions aussi à l'esprit
qu'il fallait d'abord qu'il y ait un
texte qui sorte du Sénat et si possible
un texte qui sort du Sénat avec des
marqueurs forts sur la fermeté de la
politique migratoire que nous souhaitons
voir être mise en place et donc de ce
point de vue-là je pense que on avance
bien par rapport à un certain nombre de
mesures que réclamament les républicains
depuis très longtemps et en même temps
on avait quand même à cœur de ne pas
mettre à mal la majorité sénatoriale
parce qu'il y a un compromis on va quand
même l'expliquer il va y avoir un
article additionnel qui dit que les
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers entention pourront être
régularisés sur appréci
du préfet un additionnel après l'article
4 pour être tout à fait précise euh
c'est ce qui se fait déjà aujourd'hui ça
existe sauf que aujourd'hui voilà ça
rentre dans la loi et donc à travers ce
nouvel article qui a été écrit avec
l'assentiment des deux présidents du
groupe faisant la la majorité
sénatoriale et bien on encadre plus
strictement le pouvoir de régularisation
des préfets et on fait en sorte aussi
que que les critères de la circulaire
Vals soient eux aussi mieux encadrés
beaucoup plus strictes par rapport à
l'appréciation que va donner le préfet
au cas par cas sur chaque étranger en
situation irrégulière sur ses métiers
entention qui souhaiterait pouvoir
bénéficier d'un titre de séjour et donc
là il y a une série de critères qui sont
particulièrement précis et sur lequel et
bien le le pouvoir discrétionnaire du
préfet jouera de façon à éviter à éviter
un appel d'air et de façon également à
éviter qu'une prime soit donnée à la
fraude à l'illégalité pour parler
trivialement est-ce qu'il y en a chez UC
ou au groupe LR qui sont en train de
manger leur chapeau dans ce compromis un
compromis il faut faire un pas de part
et d'autre mange un ch je crois que
aujourd'hui non pas forcément mais je
pense que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
la majorité sénatoriale a tenu et que
pour autant on n pas renoncé à nos
convictions à travers ce texte de loi
qui qui nous est présenté fermeté mais
aussi bien évidemment quand on doit
régulariser des étrangers au regard de
ce qui se fait déjà ne pas créer d'appel
d'air et faire en sorte que
véritablement ce soit des étrangers qui
aent envie et qui aient toutes les
capacités au niveau de leur travail de
leur intégration sociale de leur
insertion de leur adhésion au mode de
vie puisse effectivement à ce momentl
être régularisé par les préfets je ve
bien sûr vous faire ré réagir vos
collègues en plateau mais on va écouter
tout de suite Isabelle Floren on va
entendre vos partenaires de la majorité
sénatoriale la sénatrice Union centriste
des hautes c est au micro d'Alexandre
Poussard bonjour Isabelle Floren bonjour
al on va écouter les autres acteurs de
cette négociation finalement cette
version de compromis cet article de loi
car il y en aura bien un qui permet des
régularisations de travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension mais
à la discrétion du préfet au cas par cas
en fait c'est ce que demandaient les
centristes écoutez oui c'était ce que
nous souhaitions et nous souhaitions
avant tout pouvoir aboutir à une
discussion et un compromis avec le
groupe LR de la majorité sur ce sujet et
nous sommes effectivement tout à fait
satisfaits qu'un accord ait pu être
trouvé on l'avait dit dès notre
discussion générale et bien sûr bien
avant dès la première discussion en
commission que nous
souhaitions pouvoir obtenir à la
discrétion comme l'a dit madame la
Présidente sur le plateau à la
discrétion des préfets au cas par cas
mais pouvoir obtenir cette
régularisation qui nous semblait
importante de ces travailleurs sans
papier mais qui travaill sur notre sol
depuis souvent de longues années donc
c'est un c'est un bon compromis nous
sommes tout à fait satisfait et encore
plus satisfait finalement que nous
puissions je l'espère en tout cas à la
fin de la semaine aboutir à un texte au
Sénat c'était aussi notre vœux car comme
vous le savez le sondage du weekend n'a
dit que entre 70 et 80 plus de 80 % des
Français attendent des solutions de la
fermeté et du pragmatisme et je pense
que cet accord va nous permettre
d'aboutir à un bon texte pour not Sénat
pour le Sénat et c'est tout à notre
honneur alors si on regarde précisément
et bien cette version de compromis qui a
été conclu entre la droite et le centre
au Sénat et bien effectivement les
préfets vont pouvoir contrôler chaque
dossier de travailleurs sans papier dans
les métiers en tenstion qui demandent
leur régularisation vérifier s'il y a
une bonne intégration un mode de vie
conforme aux valeurs de la République un
respect de l'ordre public est-ce qu'au
final cela ne va pas compliquer quand
même une politique de régularisation de
travailleur sans papier avec tous les
métiers qui ont besoin de pourvoir à des
emplois je pense pas je pense qu'il
était important que ces précisions
finalement qu'elle soit notée dans
certain articles vont dans le bon sens
pour nous c'était évidemment naturel que
la préfecture puisse avoir un un droit
de regard évidemment sur le fait que
cette personne ne présente pas un
problème et un danger en dehors du fait
qu'il travail présenterait un danger
pour notre pays donc vérifier cela il
faudra ensuite évidemment voir quelles
sont les modalités d'application de la
circulaire mais je crois que nous sommes
tous d'accord et nous l'étions bien
avant la la la précision souhaitée par
le groupe LR va dans le bon sens de
toute façon et nous l'avions d'ors et
déjà dit pour nous ça semblait naturel
qu'à partir de du moment où ces
personnes sont intégrées elles
respectent évidemment les les valeurs de
notre pays c'est c'est évident c'est
bien de le rappeler dans un texte de loi
la circulaire il faut l'encadrer il faut
la préciser nous sommes d'accord sur ce
point et voir effectivement qu'il y a un
travail aussi effectif qui est fait par
ces personnes sur notre territoire ce
qui est aussi dit dans l'article 4
additionnel merci beaucoup Isabelle
Coren pour votre réaction merci merci
beaucoup Alexandre pour cette première
réaction François patria est-ce que
cette rédaction va convaincre votre
groupe parce que ça ne dénature pas ce
qui a été présenté d'abord comme la
jambe gauche du texte d'abord je vous
rappelle que le processus va se
poursuivre dans la première partie du
processus un texte au Sénat ensuite une
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale et
ensuite une CMP ça enc compliqué
attendez justement j'y viens parce que
le processus d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
celui qui sera bien entendu Infiné une
fois que l'assemblée l'aura examiner
qu'est-ce que nous voulions nous
souhaitions nous aussi que le Sénat pour
qui pour la première fois et proposé un
texte régalien en première lecture avant
l'assemblée ici aboutisse à ce que au
Sénat sorte un texte que les Français
attendent dans ce texte vous avez
compris qu'il y avait deux ou trois
points qui fait laame on pour en parler
l'article 3 et 4 et puis le code de
nationalité et puis le regroupement
familial sur l'article 3 personne n dupe
hein chacun faire un pas de côté madame
l'a évoqué à cet instant monsieur rotao
avait dit qu'il faisait une lgne rouge
du fait que des travailleurs aujourd'hui
sans papier puissent obtenir un tête de
ses jour alors on on supprime l'article
3 mais on réécrit l'article 4 qui est
qui décrit bien qu'aujourd'hui des dans
les métiers entention des travailleurs
d'origine immigré pourront obtenir un
titre de séjour c'est ce que nous
souhaitions une accroche législative qui
restera à parfaire à l'Assemblée alors
comme ici dans cette assemblée dans
cette assemblée comme nous sommes
aujourd'hui je crois des gens
constructifs que les sénateurs font
preuve de responsabilité prendre cet
article 4 bis comme une base de départ
de ce que nous soutions avoir au bout du
compte moi je dis pas ici quelqu'un a
mangé son chapeau pas manger son chapeau
je dis
aujourd'hui attendez les républicains
les républicains voulent la disparition
l'article 3 les centristes qui ne
voulaient pas voter cet amendement et
ceux qui auraient mis en minorité les
républicains vont le voter aujourd'hui
ce qui évitera ce faux drame apparent
mais dans le même temps je crois que bon
on peut dire que d'un côté l'article 3
va être supprimé de l'autre côté bah il
sera réécrit sous une autre forme un peu
différente évoqué effectivement par donc
nous nous soutiendrons la Form de
compromis qui permettra des avancés à
l'Assemblée nationale vous aussi Jérôme
dur vous en avez la même lecture on a vu
toute une partie de la gauche
rassemblé pour dire que vous vouliez
justement et bien cette régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier occupant
des métiers en tenstion ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça n'est plus un
débat parlementaire c'est un peu une
vente sur le bon coin mais on sait pas
trop qui achète quoi à quel prix et à la
fin quel produit on obtient moi je pense
que personne ne gagne vraiment
d'ailleurs cette affaire de du ion de la
majorité sénatoriale sur cette ce
compromis c'est un mariage sans amour
d'ailleurs ça a été compliqué un texte
sur lequel on n pas arrivé à se mettre
d'accord en commission c'était avant
l'été un texte dans lequel on modifie
l'ordre d'examen des articles puis
finalement on revient Paron trou ACC TR
un accord donc c'est assez compliqué
donc je suis pas certain que tout le
monde soit vraiment dans l'euphorie et
l'enthousiasme sur le terrain je pense
qu'on va rien gagner du tout parce que
le problème de la circulire Vals qui
avait d'autres vertus par ailleurs c'est
quand même l'arbitraire moi je me suis
occupé d'un d'un dossier un peu
emblématique c'était le cas ravac
boulanger qui voulait régulariser son
son employé la réalité c'est que d'un
département à l'autre c'est extrêmement
variable et la plupart des associations
qui accompagnent lespre du préfet ça va
dépendre donc on ne sort pas de
l'arbitraire on le renforce même donc je
je ne vois pas quel est le point
d'arrivée positif sur le terrain et puis
il reste bah le fait que ce soit inscrit
quand même dans la loi que on puisse pas
retirer cette circulaire et dire bah
c'est plus du tout possible de
régulariser ces personne c'est la
circulaire Vals en moins bien mais on en
conserve l'arbitraire donc je suis pas
certain qu'on qu'on y gagne vraiment et
puis pour je comprends pas ce que les
macronistes y trouvent parce que je suis
pas certain que ça convainque beaucoup
la jambe
gauche des macronistes et que à
l'Assemblée ça risque de compliquer les
choses donc voilà il faut qu'on sorte
aussi un peu d'hypocrisie on a bien vu
que Charles Darmanin voulait
s'intéresser au députés LR qui demandait
sur le terrain des régularisation
nombreus parce qu'on voit tous ce qui se
passe en réalité dans les métiers
enention et puis c'est un besoin au niau
besoinéassemblée nationale ce sera pas
le T Infiné moi je dis j'entends les
macronistes je dis pas Jérôme Durin les
mélanchonistes hein parle pas comme
ça mais je veux dire par là c'est une
base de départ ce sera pas le texte
infin la dites à V collègue LR le
compromis auquel vous êtes arrivé de
toute façon ça restera pas
attendons de voir déjà terminons la
discussion au Sénat aujourd'hui ce dont
ne voulait pas le président Bruno
rotaillot et le groupe les républicain
c'est que ce droit de régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier sur les métiers
en tension sont un droit automatique et
un droit opposable et là-dessus
effectivement Bruno rotaillot a obtenu
satisfaction puisque on renvoie à la
circulaire bals non pas en moins bien
cher Jérôme Durin mais en plus ferme et
de façon à ce que le préfet et des un
ensemble de critères qui lui permettent
vraiment d'apprécier si cette personne a
une activité professionnelle la réalité
du travail et bien évidemment un certain
nombre de paramètres extérieurs qui font
que est-ce qu'il respectent l'ordre
publi les valeurs de la République
est-ce qu'il n'a pas eu de condamnation
pénale je pense que véritablement ça
évite cet appel d'air que nous refusions
de toute façon la question c'est combien
on régularise parce que du coup on a les
besoins d'une économie tout le monde
sait qu'on a besoin de régularisation
combien on régularise est-ce que vous
pouvez aujour'hu 700 qui son régularis
par
an ça va rester comme ça j'espère que ce
sera plus et deux je voudrais quand même
rappelerendez cétait pas automatique
pour être régularisé il fallait avoir 3
ans de présence en France parler
français av va travailler pendant 8 mois
dans l'année qui précède aujourd'hui
avant cétait quand même et c'était ni
automatique ni
irréversibleosableersible donc faut pas
faire croire aujourd'hui qui était
l'appel d' don on a parlé voilà allez on
va parler aussi du reste du projet de
loi immigration qui est quand même déjà
déjà bien modifié he passé par la
moulinette de la majorité sénatoriale
qui sort durci sur de nombreux points du
débat sénatorial avec notamment vous
avez commencé à en parler hier la
suppression de l'Ame transformé en Amu
l'aide médicale d'État devient l'aide
médicale d'urgence plus restreint
écouter les débats hier dans
l'hémicycle on a bien compris ce qui
jouait avec cette loi sur l'immigration
c'est pour parti la survie de votre
mouvement politique c'est l'avenir
politique du ministre mais à un moment
donné on joue pas avec la la santé des
Françaises et des Français comment après
la covid épidémie massive comment après
la covid on va laisser des gens sans
soins sans accès aux soins et
potentiellement en étant des vecteurs
d'épidémie pour eux pour leur famille
pour la population française alors un
moment donné on arrête de jouer la
politique politicienne on se on
s'attache à la la sé des Françaises et
des Français et des étrangers et on
arrête de vouloir supprimer la me votre
réponse à Yanque Jade qui a donc sorti
tout cet argumentaire hier Dominique est
Sasson est-ce que l'aide médicale d'État
a la si rechercher alors que seulement
la moitié des étrangers qui ont droit la
demande aujourd'hui en France je
remarque Yannick Jade qui vient juste
d'arriver dans notre assemblée doit
apprendre à travailler et à voir comment
travaille le Sénat il est très souvent
dans la caricature et dans l'anathème
j'avais pu le mesurer au de l'examen de
la proposition de loi de Sophie prima
sur l'attribution et le renforcement du
rôle des le fond il reprend des
arguments que que pense l'ensemble de la
gauche pourquoi il mélange la politique
politicienne disant c'est votre survie
de votre parti c'est la survie du
ministre de l'intérieur avec un sujet
qui est un sujet de Fond important
transformer l'aide médicale d'État en
aide médicale d'urgence je on peut pas
nous faire de procès d'intention par
rapport au fait qu'on manquerait
d'humanité sauf que aujourd'hui l'aide
médicale d'État elle a un coût elle a un
coût on voit bien que aujourd'hui il y a
400000 étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui ont recours et donc ça
coûte près de 1,2 milliards d'euros par
an et cette aide médicale d'État elle a
augmenté de 12 % entre 2022 et 2023 donc
à partir du moment où on considère que N
supprime pas les soins médicaux
d'urgence et Dieu sait si le panier de
soins est encore important et oui on va
le dire ça concerne encore les maladies
graves les douleurs aigues prophylaxie
c'està-dire la prévention la grossesse
la vaccination ça ça concerne vraiment
l'urgence des personnes qui se trouvent
en situation irrégulière dans notre pays
et qui ont besoin d'être soigné et que
l'on continuera à soigner par contre
c'est des personnes qui ont besoin de
soins médicaux hospitaliers mais qui ne
sont pas dans l'urgence et bien pourquoi
continuer à les soigner en France parce
que là aussi je suis désolé c'est un
appel d'air parce que ces personnes-là
une fois qu'elles sont soignées qu'elles
peuvent avoir des soins sur une longue
durée elles ne repartent pas dans leur
pays et je vous rappelle aussi que c'est
la solidarité nationale qui pai on va
continuer à les soigner nous dit
Dominique estri ça sonne ces personnes
qui ont besoin de ces soins qui sont
étrangères l'aide médicale d'urgence
c'est aussi ce qui est appliqué dans la
majorité des pays européens Jérôme Durin
c'est ce qui s'est fait sous Nicolas
Sarkozi est-ce si problématique oui
c'est problématique et moi je vais faire
retomber un peu la pression je vais pas
aller dans l'enhase C'est pas
l'indignité l' humanité l'inefficacité
mais c'est une énorme bêtise énorme
bêtise on renonce à soigner les gens euh
alors même qu'on sait que en les
soignant pas on fait porter un risque à
l'ensemble du reste de la population que
ça coûtera plus cher parce que des soins
qui sont pas pris en temps et en heure
et forcément l'aggravation des situation
médicale coûte plus cher euh ça va finir
aux urgences au urgences on r gagé à la
fin je ne suis pas d'accord avec
Dominique est sur l'appel d'air pas plus
sur l'aide médical d'État que sur
d'autres sujets que sur l'article 3 et
quand même on demande un rapport Evin
stéphanini qui dit il faut pas se
toucher à l'aide médicale d'État 3000
médecins disent attention attention
attention franchement là on sacrifie
l'efficacité à l'idéologie et on voit
bien qu'il y a un contexte politique
dans des PL à Dominique est ça sonne il
y a le rassemblement national qui pousse
très fort et qui cour derrière les
macronistes qui sont pas loin à courir
derrière et du coup on déporte tout le
débat public sur des totems qui sont
inefficaces pour la société c'est ça le
sujet est-ce que tout le monde court
après la droite après sa droite duration
sur les macronistes alors je arrêter de
lui répondre mais je va êre d'accord
avec lui alors il
devrait
trans dans cette affaire on est dans la
posture dans la démagogie et dans la
facilité je m'explique supprimer l'aide
médicale l'État c'est une triple faute
c'est une faute éthique depuis hier je
reçois des messages de médecins de
France entière qui me disent qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette bêtise que vous avez
voté première chose faute éthique de
faute médicale parce que évidemment les
gens qui sont en maladie chronique vont
devenir en maladie plus grave parce
qu'ils sonont pas pris en compte parce
que ça va faire de l'épidémiologie en
plus ça va faire des malades en plus de
la contamination et troisièmement une
faute médicale une faute financière ça
va coûter plus cher avec ce système on
se borne à transférer personne n dupe la
médecine ambulatoire en médecine
d'hôpital tout ce qui va pas être payé
demain par par la par par la me sera
payé par l'hôpital on va donc aggraver
les finances de l'hôpital en croyant
faire plaisir aux gens parce qu'
soi-disant on soignerait plus les
immigrés donc je pense que c'est c'est
une faute c'est une erreur je l'ai dit
hier faut paser la facilité alors
pourquoi est-ce que le gouvernement hier
a donné un avis de sagesse c'est-à-dire
a refusé de vraiment se proncer sur Av
entendu hier mais je vous ai entendu
j'ai entendu clavier yovili j'ai entendu
dans votre C c'était très clair mais pas
chez le gouvernement la sagesse c'est la
réflexion et la responsabilité et quand
le gouvernement dit sagesse aujourd'hui
attendez avant de faire ça réfléchissez
en lieu à partir du moment où le
gouvernement a demandé à deux personnes
opposé politiquement et tout le monde
connaît monsieur staffinini et Monsieur
evvin très opposés politiquement de
donner un avis qui sera un avis objectif
et ben attendons d'avoir leur avis avant
de me décider c'est ça qu' dit le
gouvernement donc il faut aller vers un
avis défavorable vous dites une fois
qu'on aura les conclusions du rapport ça
sera un avis défavorable jeis comprendre
que à la fois la min le ministre et la
première ministre sont pas favorables à
ce qu'on supprime la les deux ministres
qui étaient sur le ban nétaient pas
d'accord entre eux en plus plus
globalement oui et on a vu d'ailleurs
cette opposition aussi entre Gérald
Darmanin Olivier verrand sur la M qui
l'un qui dit c'est possible l'autre qui
dit en tant que médecin ce n'est
absolument pas possible vous l'entendez
vous le voyez quand même cette moi j'ai
pas vu diff fait vot majorité so j'ai
Pasu j'ai vu hier un ministre ministre
de l'Intérieur qui est en charge du
texte qui dit
aujourd'hui si on peut avancer dans ce
texte en en avançant objectivement en
regardant les choses en attendant les
rapports et ben là je prend la sagesse
et puis une ministre madame le Baudeau
qui est dans son rôle qui dit
aujourd'hui en tant que pharmacienne en
tant que ministre enfin ministre de la
Santé par ailleurs au ministère de la
Santé j'ai des responsabilités je le dis
il y a pas d'opposition il y a une
complémentarité allez pour conclure ce
débat je voudrais que l'on dise quand
même un mot d'une autre actualité une
actualité très importante un mot de la
marche contre l'antisémitisme qui va
être organisée dimanche initiative de
Gérard Larcher et de Yael brun pivé ils
en ont fait la proposition hier dans le
Figaro qu'est-ce que vous inspire Jérôme
Durin le fait que Marine Le Pen est été
la première à annoncer sa participation
dimanche non seulement le rassemblement
national sera là mais c'est le premier à
s'être manifesté bah le ripolinage
continue c'est le
ripolinage proisraël et projuif du
rassemblement national mais qui ne
trompe personne euh moi je suis assez
ça vous dérange qu'elle qu'elle soit
présente à cette
manifestation je pense que c'est pas le
place c'est pas leur place
historiquement et c'est surtout une
imposture l'hypocrisie du rassemblement
national sur ce sujet est honteuse on
sait comment est né le rassemblement
national on sait ce qu'prend ses cadre
on sait sur quel sujet ils travaillent
dans leur colloque quel est les quelles
sont les racines profondes racistes
antisémites xénophobes du rassemblement
national donc on peut tomber dans le
panneau certains nous pas et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que le président caner a
demandé à Gérard lâcher d'exprimer son
souhait que le rassemblement national ne
soit pas présent dans cette
manifestation parce que on peut pas
défiler avec des gens qui euh pensent
l'inverse ce pré demand quoi à Gérard
l'arché de demander au rassemblement
national de ne pas venir nous nous le le
premier secrétaire du du Parti
socialiste Olivier fort qui avait fait
la proposition d'une manifestation
dimanches a dit clairement que nous
soutions pas défiler avec le rassemblée
national je pense que c'est aussi une
question de d'honnêteté intellectuelle
et de cohérence politique mais si le
rassemblement national il va quand même
vous y allez quand même vous maintenez
votre venue nous nous manifesterons ce
pour quoi n nous avons toujours combattu
c'est-à-dire euh la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme la lutte contre toutes
les formes de raciste on le fera avec
tous les gens de bonne volonté chacun
prend ses responsabilités on va pas
quitter les cortèges parce que d'autres
s'y invite et on défilera pour une cause
après nous avons dit ce que nous
pensions de la positure du rassemblement
national Dominique estri ça sonne tout
de même sur le fait que Marine Le Pen
soit la première à avoir dit qu'elle y
serait qu'elle irait dès qu'il y a eu
l'annonce euh de de de cette marche
dimanche qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
moi d'abord je tiens à saluer
l'initiative des deux présidents du
Parlement une initiative qui est
transpartisane une initiative qui est
citoyenne et républicaine parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit la haine se
banalise dans notre pays et bien sûr
l'antisémitisme porte gravement atteinte
à la cohésion et à notre Pact social
alors après c'est une mobilisation
générale de l'ensemble des personnes des
républicains qui se retrouvent dans
l'attachement aux valeurs de la
République aux valeurs de to au valeurs
de laïcité aux valeurs de liberté
ça de voir chacun où est-ce qu'il va de
quel côté il va il va se trouver je
rappelle que quand même au lendemain de
l'attaque du Hamas contre l'État
d'Israël il y a eu une manifestation qui
a été organisé par le cri il y a eu des
députés du RN qui sont venus et on n a
pas fait tout un un tas même si
aujourd'hui moi c'est pas à moi qui
l'appartient de dire qui doit y
participer moi je souhaite simplement
que ce soit les républicains les
qui se rassemble qui se mobilise qui
dénonce les porteurs de haine et qui
appelle à la défense des droit de
l'homme donc est-ce que le rassemblement
national pour vous il y a à sa place
s'il le souhaite aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national est un mouvement
qui est républicain et qui n'est pas
interd notre pays c'est votre réponse je
vois bien je vois bien votre fixation
sur le fait que Madame Le Pen vien ou
vienne pas le problème de la
manifestationifestation d'union et que
l'on voit se diviser les partis autour
de cette venue rassemblement personne
n'est divisé je vous dis aujourd'hui que
l'objectif de cette réunion
transpartisane je souscris totalement à
ce que viennent de dire mes deux
collègues ici en RS c'est l'objectif
c'est de lutter ensemble de faire à la
fois une forme d'union populaire et de
tracer un chemin de paix intérieur c'est
comme ça bon à cette manifestation elle
est organisée aujourd'hui par les deux
présidentes et présidents et je crois
que tout le monde peut y aller tout le
monde peut y en fait nous tous nous
irons nous irons soit ici soit en
province en fonction de de nos
possibilités y allez maintenant je ne
vous cache pas que je suis pas dupe de
la conversion de l'antisémitisme de
Monsieur Le Pen aujourd'hui à d'un seul
coup la cause pro pro juive de Madame Le
Pen personne n'est dupe on connait à la
fois son connait tactique
adaptation tout le monde le sait on n
pas Dupen moi sil est là je me sentirai
mal à l'aise il entendu mais je ne me
vois pas en aucun cas pouvoir interdire
quelqu'un une manifestation tout le
monde viendra je rejoins la position de
jérô sur ça si elle est là je serai mal
à l'aise j'espère qu'elle sera pas au
premier plan je sais qu'elle tira
qu'elle attira les caméras vers elle
qu'elle sera en jou d'ailleurs vous avez
vu la réaction de Mad le P vous m'avez
entendu poser les questions vous savez
que les médias vont tous regarder où se
trouve Mar bien sûr mais bien sûr je
sais mais vous avez vu quand même
monsieur Bardella il y a de jours ne
désavoue pas Monsieur Le Pen en disant
il n pas antisém et ce matin Madame Le
Pen elle-même renie totalement les
opinions de son père et dit moi je suis
dans désaccord avec lui enfit
globalement il était en sémite je ne
suis pas al bon voyez on voit bien ce
positionnement tout est bon pour
attraper aujourd'hui les voix les forces
populaires nous ne sommes pas dupes nous
ne souhaitons pas qu' so on peut pas
l'empêcher de le faire on s mal voilà
voilà mais les Français r- DUP si vous
dites que vous ne l'êtes pas estce que
on n'est pas presque à l'aboutissement
de ce processus de normalisation du
rassemement frçais c'est que notre pays
se lève pour manifester son opposition
et bien évidemment dire que
l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa place dans
notre pays et c'est cela qu'il faut
vraiment faire en sorte que le peuple
français puisse vraiment montrer cette
mobilisation qui est un criis des
consciences et qui est absolument
indispensable à l'heure où nous parlons
et si l'extrême droite pose son
antisémitisme bah tant mieux au moins on
aurgag quelque chose une toute dernière
question parce que cette cette polémique
cette actualité a effacé la précédente
celle de la réaction de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a écrit les amis du
soutien inconditionnel au massacre ont
leur rendez-vous est-ce que laanupe
c'est définitivement terminé après ça
est-ce que on doit passer du moratoire à
la fin de laanupe écoutez les les propos
de Jean-Luc Mélanchon n'engage que lui
l'ambiguité dans laquelle il est
et l'incapacité qu'il a nommé les choses
clairement est un problème pour la pour
la gauche et d'ailleurs quand on parle
de moratoire de suspension on voit bien
que s'il continue de se de creuser ce
sillon nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
choses à partager en tout cas sur ce
sujet-là le Parti socialiste est très
clair beaucoup de formations à gauche
sont très claires on aimerait bien que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit plus clair lui
aussi et bien merci merci beaucoup à
tous les trois laisse à la mélanchonie
le soin de régler ses problèmes internes
merci beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat je ne sais pas si
vous reconnaissez dans la mélanchonie la
Macron cononnait mais la malchie
jamaisz nous sommes maintenant à une
demi-heure des questions au gouvernement
nous sommes toujours avec notre duo de
journalistes avec Alexandre Poussard
salle des conférences avec audre beetas
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat audre que l'on
retrouve pour un nouveau point sur les
principaux thèmes de cette séance de
question au gouvernement Audrey Tam
c'est la situation en Israël et à Gaza
qui s'invite une nouvelle fois dans ses
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
Élisabeth borne devrait répondre à ce
sujet en tout début de séance puisque la
toute première question sera posée sur
Gaza par Guillaume Gontard le patron du
groupe écologiste et vous le savez quand
c'est un président de groupe qui pose la
question c'est la première ministre qui
lui répond Guillaume gontar qui a
plusieurs demandes il appellera
notamment à un cesser le feu un retour
de l'aide humanitaire à la libération
des otages et à un embargo des
exportations d'armes de la France à
Israël la guerre entre Israël et le
Hamas qui attise le sentiment
d'antisémitisme en France deux questions
seront posées à ce sujet par deux
groupes différents l'une du LR Dominique
del leège l'autre du socialiste Husain
Bourgi le sénateur de l'héro qui
évoquera NOTAM notamment la hausse des
actes antisémites et la nécessaire
mobilisation de tous contre ce fléo à
noter que dans son département des tags
à connotation nazi ont été apposés sur
une plaque en hommage au martyr de la
résistance vous voyez le sujet est
prignant alors qu'une grande marche
civique est organisée dimanche prochain
à l'initiative de Gérard Larcher et de
Yen Brou Pilet merci merci beaucoup
audre pour toutes ces explications on
vous retrouve maintenant dans moins
d'une demi-heure nous allons continuer à
parler de cette marche civique contre
l'anti smitisme alors que on le disait
ce moment d'union nationale voulu par le
président du Sénat et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale semble virer au
vinaigre après que le RN et reconquête
ont annoncé leur venue Fabien RER c'est
un appel qui se voulait pourtant
consensuelle face à la recrudescence des
actes antisémites une marche solennelle
dimanche à Paris à l'appel des
présidents des deux chambres une
mobilisation générale est indispensable
pour déclarer à la face du monde que la
République française ne laisse pas et
jamais ne laissera prospérer l'abjection
mais cette marche ne parvient pas à
faire l'unanimité à cause de la
participation du rassemblement national
confirmé ce matin par Marine Le Pen j'y
participerai Jordan Bardella y sera
l'ensemble de nos élus il seront et
j'appelle d'ailleurs l'ensemble de nos
adhérents et de nos électeurs à venir se
joindre à cette marche une participation
qui crée le malaise à gauche le Parti
socialiste se joindra à la mar
le rassemblement national n'a clairement
pas coupé avec ses origines antisémites
il essaie de d'utiliser l'antisémitisme
pour se racheter une une virginité et
surtout parce que ça permet de taper sur
les musulmans et donc ça ça n'est pas
possible même en Baras au parti
communiste et chez son leader Fabien
Roussel il ne s'agit pas pour nous
d'être absent d'une marche cont contre
l'antisémitisme ce que nous demandons
c'est que les contours de ce
rassemblement soient clarifiés le
rassembl national au regard de son
histoire n'a pas sa place dans un tel
rassemblement seul mouvement à s'exclure
de la marche la France insoumise les
amis du soutien inconditionnel au
massacre ont leur rendez-vous a lâché
mardi Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans un tweet
faisant allusion au bombardement
israélien sur Gaza le gouvernement lui
sera représenté dimanche tout en
affirmant que le RN n'avait pas sa place
dans la manifestation Olivier Verant a
confirmé la participation de la première
ministreabeth Bor on a entendu la
position de Fabien Rousel dans le sujet
de Fabien rard on va voir ce qu'on pense
Cécile cuquerman la présidente du groupe
communiste ici au Sénat elle est au
micro d'Alexandre Poussard salle des
conférences bonjour Cécile CUC alors les
communistes participeront à cette marche
mais ils ne marcheront pas au côté du
rassemblement national à un autre
endroit à préciser le patron du parti
Fabien Rousel quand même est-ce que ça
ne vous dérange pas de participer à une
marche contre l'antisémitisme avec des
membres du RN dans le cortège mais
d'abord moi ça ne me dérange jamais de
marcher contre l'antisémitisme je pense
que ça fait partie de notre culture de
notre histoire et cela fera partie de
notre avenir et nous serons toujours de
ceux qui dénonceront et combattront
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays oui nous
estimons que certains n'y ont pas leur
place et nous ne défilerons pas à leur
côté après je je crois que nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui de faire cette
démonstration il appartient à celles et
ceux qui veulent jouer sur les deux
tableaux de devoir se justifier mais en
tout état de cause ce n'est pas la
présence de tel ou tel qui nous exclura
de ce moment-là qui doit être je crois
très important dans notre pays la France
pour réaffirmer collectivement notre
rejet de l'antisémitisme vous demandez à
Jard arché qui a l'initiative de cette
marche avec yelbron Pivet la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale vous lui
demandez de dire que le RN n'a pas sa
place dans ce rassemblement B écoutez je
crois que Gérard Larcher fait un appel
d'abord à ce rassemblement à chacun
comme je le disais et comme l'a dit
Fabien Aussel ce matin de prendre ses
responsabilités nous nous y serons moi
je n'ai pas à commenter les faits et
gestes des uns et des autres et en tout
cas quand une sénatrice les républicains
R viient de l'entendre Dominique est
Sasson dit que le RN est un parti
républicain qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire mais moi je crois que le
rassemblée nationale n'est pas dans
l'arc républicain nous l'avons toujours
dit j'ai toujours compris fait partie de
ceux qui ont justifié et et parfois pu
construire les digues indispensables
pour les freiner on demeure pas moins
aujourd'hui qu'effectivement ils ont une
représentation nationale donc je crois
pas d'interprétation de petites phrases
mais en tout état de cause et de par
leur positionnement y compris leur
positionnement depuis 1 an à la suite
des différentes élections législatives
ils ne sont clairement pas dans ce champ
de l'arc républicain en tout cas les
insoumis n'iront pas à cette marche
contre l'antisémitisme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon estime que cela revient à
soutenir les bombardement israélien sur
la bande de Gaza est-ce que avec cette
absence d'une marche contre
l'antisémitisme il faut selon vous
définitivement rompre avec les insoumis
mais je je vois pas en quoi il y a à
rompre ou à ne pas rompre d'abord il n'y
a jamais eu de mariage donc
il n a aucun souci et je me suis déjà
exprimé sur cette antenne je veux dire
laanupese n'a jamais été quelque chose
de déposé qui a voocation à devenir un
seul parti unique c'est toujours et ça a
toujours été une alliance aux élections
législatives je crois qu'il compris
notre groupe a été très clair et et
l'intergroupe qui existe à l'Assemblée
nationale ne se réunit plus sous cette
forme aujourd'hui donc je crois quoi
tranquillisons-nous n'instrumentalisons
pas les uns et les autres ceux qui
veulent en être en seront ceux qui ne
veulent pas en être n'en seront pas nous
en tout cas les communistes je le disais
a fait partie de notre histoire nous y
serons et jamais nous nous ne lâcherons
sur l'antisémme je pas que les insouis
soient pas à cette March vous savez moi
je m'excuse quoi je suis une élue je
suis une sénatrice je n'ai pas je ne
fais pas du commentaire de la phrase
politique voilà je n'en feraai pas je
n'en ai jamais fait donc je je crois que
ça fait partie en tout cas des valeurs
fondamentales de la gauche de combattre
l'antisémitisme et pour cela parce que
nous sommes des femmes et des hommes de
gauche au Parin du parti communiste
français nous y serons dimanche merci
beaucoup cécerman pour votre réactionci
merci merci beaucoup Alexandre pour
cette nouvelle réaction sur ce plateau
je plaisir d'accueillir Catherine tricot
bonjour bonjour directrice de la revue
regard également avec nous Albert Zenou
bonjour bonjour rédacteur en chef du
service politique du Figaro l'appel de
yel brun pivé et de Gérard larch a été
lancé dans vos colonnes Albert
Zenou que pensez du fait que cette
démarche d'union soit on commence à le
pressentir un moment de discorde
politique est-ce que ça risque un peu de
faire capoter l'initiative
général je je pense pas je ce qui est
dommage c'est que c'est un c'est un
thème le le combat contre
l'antisémitisme doit toucher tout le
monde de l'extrême gauche à aujourd'hui
l'extrême droite donc euh ça devrait ça
devrait en toutous les cas mobiliser
toutes les forces politiques il se
trouve qu'il y en a une qui a toujours
qui depuis quelques temps est est un peu
trouble sur ces thème-l donc LFI pour
pas la nommer et mélanchot en
particulier qui a décidé de ne pas y
aller en mêlant unee façon un peu même
pas un peu beaucoup insidieuse le fait
de cette présence à cette grande marche
contre l'antimétisme et le soutien
indéflexible à Israël c'est deux choses
qui n'ont rien à voir et et ce qui est
dommage c'est que on en puisse on puisse
en arriver là de la part d'un d'un parti
qui qui n'avait pas cette historique là
euh de le cas de façon ancienne
récemment oui il y a il y a eu des ch F
mais on entend aussi la discorde qui n
autour de la présence du RN avec la
gauche qui demande des comptes aux
organisateurs qui dit Gérard Larcher il
faut que vous disiez que le RN n'a pas
sa place dans cette marche moi je je
trouve que le le le débat sur est-ce que
le RN est un parti fait partie ou pas de
l'arc républicain c'est un débat qui est
un peu tronqué le RN pour l'instant tous
les cas depuis que Marine Le Pen
est le dirige a toujours respecté et
même avant dit a toujours respecté les
règles républicaines il est élu de façon
républicaine ne remet pas en cause il
remet pas en cause la démocratie ne
remet pas en cause les élections il
respecte il respecte les lois à priori
donc donc pour vous il a sa place mais
totalement il a complètement sa place
c'est on ne peut pas lutter lutter
contre contre l'antisémitisme c'est pour
lutter c'est un entre soi contre contre
centre gauche et centre droit et puis
au-delà on ne veut pas non il faut que
ce soit une cause une cause nationale
faut que ça touche tout le monde et et
et jusqu'à présent Marine Le Pen a été
d'une certaine manière sur ce planl a ét
impeccable sur sur l'antimmitisme alors
son père ne l'était pas ça c'est c'est
évident les les les anciens du Front
national ne l'étaient pas c'est évident
jeanan Bardella qui a dit que Jean-Marie
Le Pen n'était pas antisémite il a pas
je pense que c'est l'une des une faute
de sa part d'avoir dit ça mais mais en
tous les cas elle elle ne l'est pas et
donc et le RN aussi on le voir on on les
a vu que soit à l'Assemblée à toujours
défendre en tous les cas le et à lutter
contre l'antisémitisme pas avoir le même
avis Catrine tricot j'imagine sur la
présence du rassemblement national ben
moi je pense que ça participe de la
confusion générale dans laquelle on est
on se trouve maintenant à discuter de
savoir si la gauche est antisémite et à
dédoiner l'extrême droite qui est
historiquement quand même d'une part de
filiation l'antisémitisme en France est
à l'extrême droite et que les gens qui
ont fondé le qui et les gens qui ont
fondé le rassemblement national pour une
part d'entre eux ont été des soutiens du
régime non seulement pééniste mais
proazis et qui ont donné des Juifs non
mais c'est NON NON excusez-moi il y a
une filiation qui n'a pas été rompue
c'està qu'il n'y a pas eu de critique
c'est pas simplement les plaisanteries
de Jean de de Jean-Marie Le Pen de
Jean-Marie Le Pen merci c'est pas
simplement ces plaisanteries qui sont en
cause c'est l'affiliation
idéologique qui n'a pas été critiqué sur
lequel il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
excusez-moi je termine vous avez eu
voilà
il n'y a pas eu de remise en cause sur
le fond des racines historiques et des
bases idéologiques sur lequel est créé
le Front national le Front national se
structure sur une base xénophobe et ça
ça reste depuis l'origine et ça continue
et ça se perpéttu alors ça prend des
formes différentes vous avez raison que
aujourd'hui on peut dire que c'est
plutôt contre les musulmans qu'ils en
ont que contre les Juifs ce cétant sur
le fond la la la racine idéologique du
Front national n'a pas été contestée
mais quand vous entendez Marine Le Pen
aujour auourd'i qui se présente comme le
premier rempart justement contre
l'antisémitisme on est dans un
renversement copernicien oui ce que je
pense c'est que le la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme parfois se fait avec en
essayant de de de faire une espèce de
billard à trois bandes c'estàd on va
essayer de jouer les juifs contre les
musulmans je m'oppose véritablement à
cette conception des choses et j'étais
très contente de voir d'ailleurs que
c'était le président de l'Assemblée la
président de l'Assemblée nationale et le
président du Sénat qui avait pris
ensemble cette initiative parce que il
en va de de l'histoire de la France de
la place que la France a fait
historiquement aux Juifs et de la place
qu'elle doit faire aujourd'hui aux
musulmans et qu'elle doit faire à la
diversité et aujourd'hui de de toutes
nos concitoyens et ce n'est pas le
propos du tout du Front National et en
ce sens je trouve problématique leur
présence et je trouve plutôt intéressant
l'idée de chercher à comment participer
à cette marche en essayant de s'en
distancer je ne sais pas si le Parti
communiste aboutira à une proposition
intéressante qui pourra rassembler plus
largement que lui-même parce que si
c'est simplement l'émittant du Parti
communiste c'est pas très passionnant
mais en revanche faire entendre que nous
n'acceptons pas cette banalisation comme
vient de le dire la sénatrice
républicain à l'instant sur le plateau
voilà j'ai trouvé ça bon je l'ai quand
je l'ai entendu je me suis dit ah bah
dis donc là ça ça galope vite du côté
des la banalisation du côté de la
banalisation de l'extrême droite vous
pouvez pas déigner à Marie Le Pen le
fait d'avoir extirpé des rangs du du
Front national
ou je pe d' d'avo d'avoirit le ménage
quand même beoup mais mais ses amis sont
toujours là mais écoutez enfin enfin les
prises de parole sont plus les mêmes non
non les prises de parole de Marine Le
Pen ne sont plus les mêmes mais pas
forcément les prises de parole de
l'ensemble des dirigeants du Front
National et ses amis qui étaient ses
copains du Gude et cetera qui sont
foncièrement antisémites continuent de
d'être autour d'elle donc on ne peut pas
me raconter on ne peut pas raconter au
français que le Front National a rompu
avec son histoire il ne l'a fait ni dans
les actes ni dans la pensée il a moi je
trouve que je là je ne suis je je suis
je suis en désaccord avec vous je pense
qu' il il a rompu avec une partie de son
histoire alors que tout ne soit pas ne
soit pas can comme de l'eau de roche cl
comme de l'au roche je veux bien mais et
donc et vous avez et et en plus déigné
au au rassemblement national sa venue au
à cette manifestation c'est c'est
empêché peut-être elle représente quand
même 11 millions d'électeurs enfin c'est
c'est c'est 40 % ou plus 42 % des
électeurs qui pour pouvoir les mettre de
côté vous dit non c'est c'est c'est
important que 42 % de gens qui ont voté
Marine Le Pen en 2022 puissent aussi
dire leur leur ralbol et le le leur le
leur opposition par c'est une marche
civique l'idée c'est aussi d'avoir des
citoyens et pas seulement les les
politiques je crois moi je crois que
l'une des solutions mais je pense qu'on
on y arrivera sans doute c'est que cette
marche les gens desfil sans banderol
sans rien enfin sans bô politique en
tous les cas il y a pas on sera je pense
pas que y a volonté de de rassembler une
partie qui défilerait sous le sous
l'égite du du Front national enfin du
rassemblement national du Parti
communiste du P du PS DLR enfin c'est
sinon l'Union nationale serait
complètement raté c'est un peu ça va un
peu l'encontre on va continuer ce face à
face on va parler de l'actualité dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat c'est l'examen bien
sûr du projet de loi immigration avec la
majorité de la droite et du centre qui
sont parvenu un accord sur la pomme de
discorde de ce texte le fameux article 3
on ne fait parler que de cela
sur Public Sénat depuis quelques jours
et tout de suite François Noël buffet le
président de la commission des lois
sénateur les républicains du rô au micro
d'Alexandre bonjour et oui Tam alors les
sénateurs les républicains et les
sénateurs centristes sont parvenus à un
accord ils sont d'accord sur la
suppression de l'article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers entention mais
dans leur compromis il y aura quand même
un article dans le projet de loi qui
permettra la régularisation de ces
travailleurs sans papier alors François
Noë buffet expliquez-nous ce que ça va
changer concrètement pour nos
téléspectateurs en réalité ça change
tout l'article 3 prévoyait une
régularisation avec certaines conditions
mais automatique de personnes étrangères
en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire qui travaillaient dans les
métiers en tension le seul fait d'avoir
un contrat de travail d'être en
situation régulière dans un métier en
tenstion permettait la régularisation
nous n'étions pas d'accord avec ce
principe nous avons toujours dit que
pour nous le système devait être de
caractère réglementaire c'est-à-dire en
réalité dans ce qu'on appelle
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour
c'est-à-dire pour être encore plus
concret du cas par cas et c'est ce que
notre accord a consacré alors justement
cet accord et bien consacre une
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier mais à la discrétion euh du euh
préfet qui pourra faire un contrôle
strict de chaque dossier vérifier
l'intégration euh du candidat également
son respect de l'ordre public des
valeurs de la République est-ce qu'au
final quand même ça ne va pas ralentir
limiter les régularisations mais pas du
tout après c'est une question
d'organisation évidemment dans les
préfectures ça ce sera le rôle du
gouvernement de mettre en place cette
organisation donc tout ça va fonctionner
parfaitement normalement mais comme vous
l'avez rappelé ça remet en place des
règles à la discrétion du préfet au cas
par cas dans le cadre de l'mission
exceptionnelle au séjour qui est un
dispositif qui existe déjà d'ailleurs
faut être bien clair le préfet ainsi
pourra constater que la demande faite
par la personne et qu'il s'intègre
parfaitement dans le paysage politique
qui est le enfin politique au bon sens
du terme dans le le respect des valeurs
de la France pour faire cours hein de la
République le fait d'avoir un certain
nombre de critères de présence sur le
territoire le fait d'avoir déjà un
contrat c'est important et puis
également l'obligation pour la
préfecture de vérifier auprès de
l'employeur la réalité du travail dont
on se prévut donc ça met un système de
contrôle assez je crois efficace assez
respectueux de ce que peut être la
personne évidemment n pas question qu'il
en soit autrement et en même temps bah
ça nous permet de faire du cas par cas
et ça c'est absolument essentiel et
c'était notre souhait politiquement cet
accord entre les républicains et les
centristes ça va permettre en fin de
semaine d'avoir une majorité sénatoriale
qui est d'accord pour adopter votre
version du projet loi immigration
écoutez quand un texte n'est pas voté il
est pas encore voté les débats vont se
continuer mais nous sommes sur la bonne
route et sur la bonne voie d'autant plus
que déjà à la commission des lois nos
rapporteurs qui sont à la fois
centristes et républicains on on fait
ont tout fait ensemble et que ce texte
en réalité il sort de la commission donc
nous sommes d'accord surtout il y a pas
de difficulté donc j'ai bon esp ir que
sorte de cette maison un un bon texte en
la matière qui donne de la cohérence à
la politique migratoire de la fermeté
quand il en faut et puis de l'humanité
bien sûr parce qu'il en faut c'est
absolument nécessaire mais qui traduit
en réalité un choix politique dernière
question rapidement sur les coulisses de
cette négociation qui dure quand même
depuis des mois entre les l et les
centristes sur cet article 3 est-ce
qu'au final ce n'est pas le président du
Sénat Jard Larché qui a dit stop ça
suffit maintenant vous vous mettez
d'accord en tous les cas il a fait
passer des messages très bien et on
finira par cette phrase merci beaucoup
franç François nel buffet d'avoir
répondu mes questions voilà merci merci
beaucoup Alexandre effectivement il a
certainement fait passer ce message là
d'ailleurs Gérard Larcher il y en a qui
sont pas du tout satisfaits quand même
dans la réécriture de cet article 3
enfin supprimé et transformé en article
additionnel et bien c'est la gauche
écoutz la sénatrice socialiste Corine
rassigin nous avons examiné ce matin en
commission des lois le fait qu'il y
aurait deux amendement de suppression
qui seront déposés et qui seraient
remplacés par une une fusion de ces de
deux articles mais dans une version très
dégradée évidemment et qui non seulement
est dégradée par rapport au projet de
loi mais en plus qui a un recul par
rapport au droits existants et donc
c'est là où on voit bien qu'il a il y a
quelque chose d'absolument scandaleux
puisque le gouvernement nous avait quand
même dit que leur but c'était d'amélorer
les choses qu' y avait un problème avec
la la question de l'accès au travail et
de l'intégration par le travail et dans
dans le droit dans les droits et la la
réglementation existante et que il
fallait l'améliorer et là ce qui font
c'est qu'ils vont au contraire dégrader
tout cela puisque il va y avoir une
version qui est encore qui est beaucoup
plus restrictive que ce qui existe
aujourd'hui avec la circulaire dite
Vals et donc avec des des conditions de
régularisation qui vont être encore
plus encore plus contraignante
aujourd'hui avec la circul Val il a
seulement à peu près 7000 personnes par
an qui sont régularisé ce qui est quand
même déjà pas beaucoup et là il y en
aura encore moins bon que la gauche
dénonce ce texte n'est pas une surprise
Catherine tricot elle dénonce aussi un
gouvernement qui va sur la position de
la droite la droite qui va sur la
position du RN on a entendu tout à
l'heure Jérôme Durin c'est le cas avec
ce texte oui pour l'essentiel je pense
que tout ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est de l'ordre du symbolique
comme vient de le rappeler la sénatrice
il s'agissait de 7000 régularisations on
va durcir le texte pour passer de 7000 à
5000 ou à 4005 c'estàd absolument à les
pur du TR je dis pas que c'est rien pour
les personnes en question c'est un recul
dommageable mais véritablement ce n'est
pas là que ça se joue ce n'était pas un
il y avait pas de transformation
d'ouverture en vérité vers la
régularisation simplement une prise en
compte de difficultés dans un certain
nombre de secteurs et peut-être une
petite avancée un principe de réalité
disaient certains voilà mais c'était
véritablement pas une révolution ni dans
un sens à mon sens ce n'est ni dans un
sens ni dans l'autre on per la jambe
gauche mais elle était déjà fragile oui
et puis on et et en vérité on ne change
pas véritablement les choses le par
contre on donne des signaux on donne le
signe que on veut faire on veut
complaire
euh à la droite et la droite elle-même
essaie de d'envoyer des signaux qu'elle
entend l'électorat d'extrême droite donc
tout ça est plutôt de l'ordre du
symbolique et du politique je regrette
vraiment le l'ambigué du gouvernement
notamment le ministre en charge du
dossier qui lui s'est d favorable à
l'évolution qui s'est dfvorable à la
suppression de la CMU qui s'est dit
favorable à la réalisation d'un
référendum sur les immigration bref il
donne géralmanin donne tous les gages à
la droite absolument et je pense qu'il
est en campagne électorale qui s'imagine
queil va réussir à à s'installer comme
un candidat bien à droite à mon avis
c'est un c'est trop tard Marine Le Pen
est là pour ça la grande difficulté de
Gérald d'Anin c'est que s'il veut
soutien de la droite et on le comprend
au Sénat où la droite et sentre son
majoritaire il ne faut pas non plus
qu'il s'alienne le soutien de sa
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale ça
paraît quasiment impossible
euh il va falloir donner aussi des gages
à la gauche
puisque Sacha
aoulier le groupe en gros de la majorité
ENF groupe de gauche de la majorité
en la majorité n'entend pas du tout
laisser tomber cet article 3 on les a vu
se joindre même avec la gauche du Sénat
en conférence de presse en déb semain
bien sûr donc il y aura une bataille qui
se jouera à l'Assemblée alors est-ce que
est-ce que l'exécutif arrivera à tordre
le coup à cette gauche là est-ce qu'elle
donnera des des des gages des gages à
une partie partie de sa majorité qui qui
n'entend pas voter ce texte pour
l'instant l'État mais il y a aussi la
droite à à l'Assemblée parce que là pour
l'instant le Sénat les centristes et et
la droite se sont mis d'accord et ont
joué une partition à deux euh mais
est-ce queolivier marlex le patron des
députés LR à l'Assemblée est-ce que Eric
cioti sont aussi alignés que ça sur cet
article refondé que comme les dis
Catherine ça changera pas beaucoup c'est
un accord winwin entre la entre la entre
la droite et et le le centre parce que
chacun y trouve son compte paracord
winwin entre la droite et le centre on
va voir s'il se sent winner Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe Union
centriste il est justement au micro
d'Alexandre Hervé Marseille bonjour
bonjour cet accord ce compromis trouvé
entre les sénateurs les républicains et
les sénateurs centristes est-ce que
c'est pas un peu une petite victoire des
centristes parce que vous demandiez un
article de loi qui
permettait des régularisations de
travailleurs sans papier à la discrétion
du préfet donc voilà vos conditions sont
remplies écoutez on a eu la même
position euh depuis le mois de février
98 % du texte a été voté en mars et nous
avions cette position il fallait une
accroche dans la loi bon euh c'est ce
qu'on a réussi à obtenir après euh nos
collèguue et l'air ont voulu muscler euh
sur la ligne qui était là l'heure le
texte mais euh vous prenez mon
amendement et vous avez l'essentiel de
ce qu'on a voté donc voilà je pense que
l'essentiel c'était surtout qu'il a un
texte qui sorte du Sénat euh car c'est
devenu ici le point d'équilibre de nos
institutions on l'a vu au moment de
l'affaire des retraites il fallait qu'il
y ait un texte qui sortent et qui
aillent à l'Assemblée on a obtenu
beaucoup d'ailleurs au demeurant et donc
si il n'y avait pas de texte c'est le
texte d'origine qui aurait été discuté à
l'Assemblée c'est-à-dire qu'on aurait
perdu toutes les avancées sur le
regroupement familial sur les visas
étudiants sur les soins et cetera et
cetera donc c'était important que il y
ait un texte qui sorte du Sénat et je
pense que pour ça c'est ça avec cet
accord voilà c'est réglé il y aura une
adoption par la majorité sénatoriale de
cette version durci quand même du projet
de loi immigration oui et puis sur ceux
qui s'inquiètent d'un certain nombre de
discussions qui ont pu y avoir sur la me
ou sur d'autres
sujets écoutez il y a une phase de
discussion ça sera l'assemblée puis aura
une phase 3 ça sera la CMP donc vous
voyez il y a encore du grain moudre
comme on disait chez foo il y a quelques
temps et donc et justement si si on se
projette un peu sur la phase 3 de
négociation c'està-dire entre sénateur
et députés est-ce que cette restriction
qui a été votée hier de l'aide médicale
d'État qui a été votée par la droite et
le centre ici au Sénat est-ce que cette
restriction de l'aide médicale d'État
c'est ça peut être une variable de
négociation selon vous bon chacun peut
avir son idée làdus visiblement les
républicains il tenaent beaucoup je
pense quand même que ça se discute je
rappelle quand même que tous les
demandeurs d'asile bénéficient de ce
qu'on appelle la Puma l'aide médicale
elle est automatique hein la
même voilà que pour vous et pour moi
donc il y a encore beaucoup de choses
qui se font mais je pense que nos
collègues de l'Assemblée il faut leur
laisser aussi quelques débats et ils
vont se jeter avec délectation là-dessus
vous pensez que la majorité
présidentielle notamment son n gauche
peut voter cette version de compromis
que vous avez trouvé je leur laisse le
soin de de discuter nous on fait notre
job si je puis dire ici au Sénat et je
pense qu'on a bien entamé les choses
donc il faut qu'on leur laisse un peu de
travail dernière question rapidement sur
la marche contre l'antisémitisme qui a
été appelé à l'initiative de gerérard
Larché Bron Pivet est-ce que le
rassemblement national a sa place dans
cette marche et est-ce que justement
gerérard ararché doit dire que le RN n'a
pas sa place dans cette manifestation
écoutez euh je pense que c'est avant
tout une marche contre l'antisémitisme
et donc il est indispensable qu'il y ait
un sursaut dans ce pays euh parce que ça
devient ignoble il y a il y a un
antisémitisme maintenant qui est qui ne
se cache pas qui est évident euh euh et
je pense que LFI à sa part dans dans
cette action après
que on interdise aux uns ou aux autres
de venir c'est compliqué surtout à des
gens qui sont élus
euh je vois pas comment on fait pour des
parlementaires élus de leur dire vous ne
pouvez pas venir c'est à eux de savoir
s'il doivent venir ou pas merci beaucoup
r Marseille pour votre
réaction merci merci beaucoup Alexandre
une toute dernière question pour revenir
quand même sur ce projet de loi sur
l'immigration on voit qu'il y a très peu
de chance pour que ce soit le même texte
au Sénat à l'Assemblée on dit que
finalement c'est plutôt un projet de loi
politique pour afficher une certaine
fermeté aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça va
être une négociation d'équilibre à
l'intérieur notamment de la macronie
pour savoir si quelle est la jambe qui
va l'emporter voilà en quelques secondes
également Albert il y a eu c'est le ce
serait ce sera le 30e texte sur
l'immigration depuis depuis une une plus
de 20 ans donc c'est un 30e texte qui a
priori ne devrait pas changer
grand-chose même
si il il est un peu plus restrictif que
autres il va dans un sens qui convient
un peu plus à la droite et bien merci
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce face- à face tout de
suite on rejoint audre vetas dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat Audrey
l'immigration va en entendre parler
aussi lors de cette séance de question
au gouvernement oui car les sénateurs
sont en plein examen du projet de loi
sur le sujet ça n'a échappé à personne
et ça colore leur question d'actualité
au Gouvernement plusieurs d'entre elles
seront directement adressées à géralde
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur deux
questions du groupe Union centriste
porteront sur des thèmes très précis la
position des des maires face au mariage
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière et
puis l'autre question portera sur un
arrêt de la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne qui restreint les
possibilités de refoulement le groupe
Les Indépendants s' par aussi du sujet
Lord Arcos interrogera l'exécutif sur la
situation des mineurs non accompagnés et
enfin question aussi chez les
socialistes ce sera à propos de l'aide
médicale d'État qui a été supprimé hier
en séance dans l'hémicycle malgré
l'opposition de la gauche le
gouvernement était divisé sur le sujet
il a émis un invis sagesse Patrick
hanner le patron du groupe socialiste
devrait interpeller ellisabeth bornne à
ce sujet lui demander des explications
vous voyez une séance qui s'annonce
musclétame une séance qui va donc être
tout à fait colorée par le projet de loi
en cours de débat actuellement au Sénat
ce projet de loi sur l'immigration et
sur lequel on l'a bien expliqué la
droite et le centre sont parvenus à se
mettre d'accord sur la suppression de
ces fameux articles 3 et cela tandis que
l'on voit et bien le président du Sénat
qui va bientôt quitter le cabinet de
départ le voici euh voilà que l'on voit
qu'il franchit et bien la galerie des
bustes qui jxte l'hémicycle voilà sous
les tambours de la Garde
Républicaine il va pouvoir et bien
rejoindre le plateau le plateau d'où il
va pouvoir présider cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement une séance qui
on vous l'a expliqué va porter largement
sur cette question de l'immigration il y
aura aussi une question sur
l'antisémitisme du côté notamment du
groupe socialiste mais aussi une une
question sur Gaza qui va ouvrir cette
séance de questions c'est le président
du groupe écologiste Guillaume Gontard
d'ailleurs qui va être le premier à
interpeller le gouvernement sur ce ce
sujet Guillaume grontard donc qui vair
prier ministre qui va lui répond
précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je donne la parole immédiatement au
président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre 30 jours 30
jours que Gaza est bombardé jour et nuit
30 jours de siège sans aide humanitaire
sans eau sans vivre sans
refuge jours qui transforme cette prison
en cimetière à ciel ouvert avec des
milliers de morts civiles dont des
milliers d'enfants 30 jours où le droit
légitime à se défendre s'est transformé
en vengeance aveugle et illégale 30
jours d'angoisse pour les otages et
leurs familles 30 jours de violation du
droit international 30 jours où sous
couvert de combattre le terrorisme on le
nourrit et le renforce Dominique de
Villepin le rappeléit encore hier ni la
force ni la vengeance n'assure la paix
et la sécurité seul la justice peut le
faire 30 jours que nous attendons une
parole forte et claire de la France pour
in cesser le feu le retour de l'aide
humanitaire et la libération des otages
le soutien inconditionnel de la France
aux opérations militaires d'Israël et à
l'occupation est une erreur tragique qui
marquera l'histoire de façon dramatique
cela ne sert ni les Israéliens ni les
Palestiniens depuis 10 ans la France a
vendu 209 millions d'euros d'armes vers
Israël bomb roquettes missile utilisé
contre la population de Gaza la France a
pourtant ratifié le traité sur le
commerce des armes de l'ONU dont
l'article 6 prévoit l'arrêt des
exportations si ses armes sont employées
pour commettre un génocide des crimes
contre l'humanité destat des attaques
dirigées contre des civils ou des crimes
de guerre nous ne pouvons pas attendre
un jour de plus madame la Première
ministre à la veille de la conférence
humanitaire la France a une occasion de
faire entendre une voix forte singulière
et courageuse comptez-vous adopter un
arg sur les ventes d'armes comme l'avait
fait le général de Gaulle lors de la
guerre des 6 jours comptez-vous
reconnaître l'état palestinien comme l'a
voté le Parlement en 2014 comptez-vous
appeler à l'arrêt et au retrait des
colonisations pour préserver la solution
à deux états madame la Premier ministre
face à cette folie meurtrière nous avons
besoin de réponsse précises
[Applaudissements]
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur monsieur le sénateur Guillaume
Gontard depuis les terribles attaques
terroristes perpétrées par le Hamas
contre Israël la situation dans la
région est extrêmement
préoccupante Israël a le droit d'assurer
la sécurité de son territoire mais cela
doit se faire dans le respect du droit
international et nous devons
impérativement éviter l'escalade et
l'embrasement dans la région et je le
dis sans ambiguité la situation
humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza est
dramatique le bilan humain est
extrêmement lourd avec de nombreuses
victimes civiles notamment des femmes et
des enfants les population palestinienne
ne doivent pas payer pour les crimes du
Hamas elles doivent être protégées de
toute urgence cette urgence la France
n'a cessé de la réaffirmer et nous avons
condamné très clairement les frappes
contre les personnels humanitaires et
les sites de l'ONU comme nous l'avons
dit le droit international humanitaire
impose des principes clairs de
distinction de nécessité de
proportionnalité et de
précaution la protection des civils est
à la fois un impératif moral et une
obligation internationale une trêve
humanitaire immédiate et durable est
absolument nécessaire elle doit pouvoir
mener à un cesser le feu monsieur le
Président Gontard la France est
mobilisée pour la paix à l'initiative du
Président de la République une
conférence humanitaire Inter inter
nationale pour la population civile de
Gazin à Paris j'ajoute que nous suivons
de très près la situation de nos
ressortissants dans la bande de Gaza
nous nous mettons tout en œuvre pour
leur permettre de revenir en France plus
de 100 ont pu quitter Gaza depuis
vendredi dernier de plus nous restons
mobilisés pour obtenir une libération
immédiate et sans conditions des otages
monsieur le Président Gontard face à ce
conflit la seule issue possible est une
solution politique avec de de états
c'est la position invariable de la
France c'est le sens de l'initiative
pour la paix et la sécurité pour tous
porté par le Président de la République
autour de trois piliers la sécurité avec
une lutte implacable contre le
terrorisme le soutien humanitaire avec
une réponse internationale rapide et
forte face à l'urgence de Gaza et la
détermination à relancer un processus
politique permettant de garantir la
sécurité d'Israël et la création état
pour les populations palestiniennes face
à la situation au Proche Orient la
France ne ménage aucun effort pour
éviter l'embrasement pour protéger les
civils et pour offrir une perspective de
Pai je vous remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est au président
Dominique deè pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mes chers
collègues
plus de 1000 actes antisémites depuis le
7 octobre des croix gamé des étoiles de
David tagué sur les murs des lettes de
menace des Français parce qu'ils sont
juifs sont agressé verbalement et
parfois même physiquement jusqu'à leur
domicile une haine qui s'affiche même
jusque dans le
métro madame la Première ministre
comment comment la France en est-elle AR
là quelles sont les causes selon vous et
comment comptez-vous lutter contre cet
antisémist d'atmosphère qui cangra notre
société pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur mon
géralin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le
sénateur il est tout à fait vrai qu'il y
a en France une explosion des actes
antisémites ces fait étaient déjà haut
avant l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
contre la population
israélienne mais il est évident que
désormais les 1159 actes antisémites
relevés depuis le 7 octobre dernier
correspondent à trois fois plus
d'événements antisémites quenun pour
toute l'année
2022 ces événements dramatique les
agressions verbales des croixgamés en
effet des étoiles de David posé là où on
pense qu'il y a des Français de
confession juif qui habitent des
agressions physiques aussi vous l'avez
dit ont fait naître 518 interpellations
par la police et par la gendarmerie
parce queà la demande du Président de la
République et de la première ministre
nous avons dès le premier jour dans les
950 lieux où les Français de confession
juives ont l'habitude d'amener leurs
enfants à l'école vivre leur culte ou
simplement vivre nous avons mobilisé
quasiment 11000 policiers gendarmes et
militairees de sentinelle qui ont pu
protéger donc contre de très nombreux
actes antisémites et interpeller des
personnes qui voulaient passer à l'acte
je voudrais aussi dire monsieur le
sénateur que la haine est traquée sur
Internet et désormais c'estes 7726
signalements qui ont été adressés à la
plateforme Faros et nous avons identifié
296 de ces personnes faisant nêtre
encore aujourd'hui de nombreuses
interpellations pour que la haine et les
menaces sur Internet soit évidemment
condamné par la justice j'ai pris des
dispositions très claires pour que les
personnes qui sont étrangères 120
d'entre elles sur les quasi 500
interpellations voil leur retrait
systématique de titre de séjour une
quarantaine d'entre eux sont en centre
de rétention administratif et nous avons
déjà commencé comme vous l'avez vu les
éloignements parce qu'on ne peut pas
toucher un Français de confession juif
un juif en France sans toucher toute la
République et je veux vous dire
malheureusement que cette antisémite
touche tout l'Occident mais en France
les Français de confession juive tous
les Juifs en France ont l'absolue
protection de la République toucher un
juif en France France c'est touché on le
sait toute la France les policiers et
les gendarmes pour qui ont pris tous les
samedis à la synagogue le savent très
bien et rendre au juifs de France un peu
la protection et l'amour qu' leur donne
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci de cette réponse mais
vous conviendrez avec moi que pour
traiter le mal il faut le prendre à la
racine il faut accepter d'identifier
sans tabou ses origines et ses ressorts
l'antisémitisme déguisé en compassion
palestinienne se nourrit du wisme et de
sa haine de la culture occidentale dans
ce domaine comme dans tout
[Musique]
autre dans ce domaine comme dans tout
autre il n'y a pas de place pour le en
même temps oui il y a une culture
française qui puiss ses valeurs dans
notre histo ire judéochrétienne comment
s'étonner de l'échec de l'intégration si
nous doutons nous-mêmes de notre
histoire de nos valeurs de notre culture
lorsque nous les dédigerons pas au nom
du
multiculturalisme la vérité et que nous
avons sous couvert de tolérance ou
d'accommandement d'irraisonnable
renoncer à notre identité et à notre
culture pour épouser un relatisme
culturel qui montre aujourd'hui ses
limites et ses effets d'lé teres depu
nombreuses années des voix se sont
élevées nous avons refusé de les
entendre déjà en
1894 en
1894 Anatole France dans le list rouge
écrivait l'antisémitisme c'est la mort
entendez-vous de la civilisation
européenne des propos bien
d'actualité
merci la parole est à notre collègue NAD
JAV pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et
indépendants merci monsieur le Président
mais mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues du pas decalais à
l'occcitanie les tempêtes siaran et
Domingo sont traversé notre pays la
Bretagne et le finisterère en
particulier ont été lourdement touchés
des rafales de 207 kmh à la pointe du
rat 193 km/h à l'île debas trois
personnes ont perdu la vie dans l'aine
au Havre et à pontavine dans le
Finistère où Frédéric Despo employé
d'éneddis est décédé en intervention je
souhaite également souligner le
remarquable travail du préfet du
Finistère à travers lui l'ensemble de la
chaîne de secours et les services de
l'État avec le déclenchement du
dispositif fr alerte et la
sensibilisation de la population en
amont des vies ont probablement été
sauvées je n'oublie pas la formidable
implication de nos élus et de nos agents
territoriaux qu'il soit dans cet
hémicycle remercié vivement des
difficultés perdure évidemment manque
d'électricité d'accès au téléphone suite
à de nombreux dégâts les Finistériens
impactés sont résilients et solidaire
mais l'inquiétude est immense
particulièrement dans le secteur
agricole des cassés écrasés des
bâtiments parfois ancien dégradés des
éleveurs privés d'eau et d'électricité
la profession évalue le préjudice pour
la ferme finistérienne à près de 200
millions d'euros c'est considérable
aujourd'hui leur leur moral est très
affecté plusieurs agriculurs
agriculteurs me le disent il sera
difficile de repartir ils ont besoin
d'un soutien fort monsieur le ministre
comment aider et faciliter les démarches
s'assurer que les matériaux de
reconstruction sont disponibles que les
aides pâac ne seront pas pénalisé par la
perte des arbres quel accompagnement
pour des agriculteurs toujours au
rendez-vous de la solidarité ils l'ont à
plusieurs fois prouvé aujourd'hui ils
dégagent encore les arbres sur les
routes l'an dernier ils aidaient les
pompiers à éteindre le feu dans les
monondaré je je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
Marc fou merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice avait
d'abord pour me joindre à ce que vous
avez dit c'est-à-dire saluer l'ensemble
des services publics ceux des
collectivités locales et ceux de l'État
et qui se sont mobilisés durant cette
tempête rendre hommage aussi aux trois
victimes à la victime évidemment à la
personne qui travaille pour anéis qui
venait d'une autre région qui était venu
en fort dans votre propre département et
rendre hommage à toutes celles et ceux
qui se sont battus pour essayer de ici
rétablir l'électricité ou de répondre à
la détresses de tel ou tel vous
m'interrer en particulier sur la
question de la détresse des agriculteurs
et qui ont été particulièrement touchés
comme d'autres j'y pense aujourd'hui
aussi sont touchés en particulier dans
le Pas de calé parce que c'est une
succession d'événements climatiques que
nous avons devant nous je vrais vous
donner les éléments de la palette de
solutions sur lesqueles nous travaillons
pour commencer à vous donner des
éléments concrets sachant que je me
rendrai la semaine prochaine dans le
finisterère dans votre département pour
évoquer ces questions s'agissant d'abord
des pertes de récoles ce c'est c'est le
nouveau système assuranciel que vous
avez voté d'ailleurs au Sénat aussi qui
va entrer en vigueur qui va s'appliquer
deux précisions la première c'est que le
nouveau système prévoit une indemnité de
solidarité y compris pour les non
assurés donc qui pourront être couverts
en partie par ce système deuxièmement
parfois le seuil de 50 % des pees pour
accéder à ce système assuranciel est un
peu trop bas si je peux dire ou un peu
trop selon la façon dont on le regarde
on est en train de regarder s'il y aura
s'il y a des trous dans la raquette et
s'il y a un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui ne seraient pas trop
touchés et qui nécessiteraiit pas qu'on
est pas par exemple un fond de soutien
ou un fond de crise comme on l'a pu le
faire sur d'autres événements
climatiques type grê ou gel et donc on
travaille dessus pour compléter si
jamais ils ne peuvent pas accéder à cela
deuxièmement vous avez évoqué aussi les
pertes de fonds qui sont des pertes
importantes je pense aux fraises mais
pas seulement aux fraises certains
relèvent du régime des catastrophes
naturelles le ministre daranin l'a dit
hier sur d'autres relèves du régime des
calamités agricoles comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous allons
activer ces deux mécanismes dans les
jours qui viennent selon les critères
que vous connaissez nous sommes en en
train de regarder donc les uns seront
couverts par catastrophe naturel les
autres par régime de calamité selon la
nature de l'ouvrage nous sommes en train
de regarder s'il y a pas nécessité
d'aller plus loin je note avec intérêt
d'ailleurs ce qu'a dit le président de
la Région Bretagne qui était qui a dit
qu'il était capable en souhait de
soutien sur les questions
d'investissement et donc nous
regarderons en complément de ces
dispositifs s'il y a pas lieu
d'accompagner les investissements enfin
juste un mot pour dire qu'on a besoin
d'aller vite il y a des besoins de
madœuvre il y a des besoins de matériel
et nous sommes aussi en train de les
documenter pour faire en sorte que
rapidement la mise en production puisse
se refaire dans un département très
touché comme beaucoup d'autres
départements de
l'Ouest merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue Lord Arcos pour le groupe
des indépendants République et
territoire merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
alors que s'ouvr aujourd'hui les Assises
Nationales des départements de France je
souhaiterais évoquer la question de
l'accueil des mineurs non accompagnés
l'afflu massif des mineurs isolés
étrangers sur le territoire français
constitue un véritable casse-tête pour
les départements qui Assur la protection
d'enfance même s'ils ont conscience que
cet exode reste dramatique pour la
plupart d'entre eux leur prise en charge
pe très lourdement sur sur les budgets
départementaux 1,5 milliards d'euros à
minima et les compensations financières
de l'État sont dérisoires à l'heure où
les droits de mutations à titre onéreux
sont en train de s'effondrer ce sont 80
millions d'euros en moins pour mon
département de lessonne par exemple il
n'est pas incongru d'exiger de l'éint un
soutien plus conséquent les structures
d'accueil sont saturées malgré les
efforts des départements pour dégager de
nouvelles solutions d'hébergement
spécialisé de plus la loi relative à la
protection des enfants dit la loi taé
interdit à partir de 2000 24
l'hébergement dans les hôtels de mineurs
confiés à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
j'avais déposé sur le projet de loi de
immigration et intégration deux
amendements l'un pour demander que
l'accueil des mineurs de plus de 16 ans
puisse être réalisé dans des structures
d'hébergement hôtelier en mobilisant des
dispositifs d'accompagnement le second
pour exclure toute prise en charge des
mineurs délinquants par la zeœu ils ont
malheureusement été déclarés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 40
madame la ministre les départements
demande la mise en œuvre de deux mesures
d'une part le transfert à l'état de la
compétence de mise à l'abri des
personnes se présentant comme mineurs
non accompagnés le temps de l'évaluation
de leur minorité par le Département
d'autre part la compensation à l'uroprès
des dépenses engagées pour la prise en
charge des MNA reconnu comme tel aussi
je souhaite vous poser les questions
suivantes tout d'abord la politique
migratoire étant une compétence
régalienne l'État est-il prêt à tendre
la main au département dans l'accueil de
ces jeunes migrants au moment de leur
arrivé sur le territoire français
deuxièmement l'État est-il prêt à un
effort financier conséquent et pérenne
pour soulager les départements et les
personnels de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
pour qu'il accueille des MNA est un défi
permanent je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre
déléguée chargée des collectivité
territorialeadame merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice D'cos alors permettez-moi pour
commencer de rappeler un principe auquel
je suis nous
sommes profondément attachés un enfant
isolé sur le territoire français doit
quel que soit sa nationalité être
protégé le doigt français consacre
explicitement ce principe c'est pourquoi
tout mineur non accompagné confié à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance laaz est pris
en charge dans les mêmes conditions que
les enfants de nationalité française
depuis 2016 l'État soutient les
départements à travers un dispositif de
répartition équilibré des MNA sur le
territoire mais aussi une aide
financière pour compenser une partie des
coûts liés à leur prise en charge la loi
du 7 février 2022 a fait évoluer la
prise en charge des MNA au bénéfice de
tous pour protéger des enfants mais
aussi parce que cela arrive lutter
contre les abus et réprimer ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles depuis ce
printemps nous avons renforcé les moyens
à la frontière et dans les services de
l'État dans les Alpes Maritimes
particulièrement qui ont été les plus
touchés le préfet a réquisitionner des
locaux nous avons proposé une aide pour
évaluer ces mineurs début septembre le
gouvernement a lancé une enquête flash
pour faire un état des lieux des
difficultés de prise en charge rencontré
par les départements et en tirer les
leçons sur cette base avec Charlotte
cobel avec Gérald armanin avec Éric
Dupont Moretti autour de madame la
Première ministre nous travaillons à des
solutions de moyen et de long terme nous
ferons tout pour trouver un consensus
avec les départements c'est sur la base
de cette mission et de la concertation
avec l'ensemble des acteurs que nous
pourrons alors prendre des mesures
pertinentes il s'agit d'enfants notre
mobilisation est totale et entière et je
complète en disant que vendredi nous
irons à l'Assemblée des départements de
France autour de madame la Première
ministre et que nous aurons l' échanger
avecx directement
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Christian Billac pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues mes amis au secours c'était le
CR d'alarme de l'abbé Pierre il y a
bientôt 70 ans marquant son combat en
faveur de Sal logie aujour aujourd'hui
les contraintes de rénovation
énergétique les spéculations sur les
locations saisonnières le zan
l'inflation les taux d'intérêt d'emprunt
élevés sont autant de facteurs aggravant
la crise du logement déjà le secteur du
bâtiment qui représente 6 % du PIB
1273000 salariés et 43000 entreprises
artisanales en r des répercussions les
chiffres sont alarmants nombre de permis
moin
mise en chantier 21 % construction
individuelle 24 % chute des ventes entre
33 et 38 % quand le bâtiment va monsieur
le ministre tout va mais quand il ne va
pas monsieur le ministre il faut agir
rapidement car le secteur du bâtiment
est un pas beau beaucoup de temps
sécoule entre le moment où on remet les
moteurs en route et le moment où le
navire retrouve sa vitesse de croisière
mais sit faation vous supprimez le
dispositif
et vous écarter nombre de communes de
nouveaux prix à taux zéro et une fois de
plus ce sont les territoires ruraux
supposé hors tension qui sont oubliés et
pourtant les besoins à logement ils sont
énormes et l'accès à la propriété est un
fort facteur d'attractivité sans aide
l'accès à la propriété pour les jeunes
couples est quasiment impossible alors
qu'ils assurent la survie des communes
rurales leur viité sociale et
associative sans nos coupes plus d'éces
c'est pourquoi je vous demande que les
zones rurales soient élugibles aux
nouvelles conditions du pczd vous
assurerez ainsi l'attractivité rurale
qui sans cette décision continuera
encore et toujours à se
désertifier pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre délégé en charge du
logement Monsieur Patrice
vergr vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur bac comme je l'ai
évoqué hier en commission des affaires
économiques il nous semble nécessaire de
faire évoluer notre modèle de
développement territorial pour l'adapter
aux nouveaux enjeux auxquels sont
confrontés nos territoires aujourd'hui
le lien emploi logement la transition
écologique la diversité des situations
locales pour n'en citer que que
quelques-uns c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons faire évoluer
les instruments de la politique du
logement et plus particulièrement le
préato zéro dans le casadre du projet de
loi finance nous avons donc proposé de
prolonger le préateau Z0 jusqu'en 2027
et de l'ADAPT aux différentes situations
locales en zone tendue là où il faut
absolument construire de nouveaux
logements nous avons souhaité le
concentrer sur le neuf avec davantage de
public éligibles et une aide renforcée
augmenter en zone détendue nous avons
déjà maintenu l'accession sociale la
propriété dans le ne9 et donc en BRS en
PSLA et dans les quartiers de la
politique de la ville pour le reste des
Primot acccédents nous avons choisi de
nous concentrer sur l'acquisition
rénovation pourquoi ce choix quelques
chiffres pour l'illustrer dans la Creuse
aujourd'hui nous avons plus de la moitié
des logements qui sont en diagnostic de
performance énergétique FG des poirs
thermiques et nous avons un taux de
acances de 15 % dans le Cantal c'est 43
% de passoir thermique et 12 % de
vacances vous comprenez évidemment que
dans ces territoires il nous faut
privilégier l'aide publique sur
l'acquisition rénovation à cela s'ajoute
la prime de sortie à la vacance initié
dans le cadre de France ruralité animé
par Dominique fort ma collègue et je
suis tout à fait prêt d'ailleurs avec
Dominique à signer des pactes de
rénovation avec les départements les
intercommunalités et les communes qui
seraient volontaires justement pour pour
engager cette transition demain et
adapter nos éudes politiques du logement
aux réalité local merci monsieur le
sénateur notre collègue h BG pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues l'écrivain martiniqu Fran
Fanon écrivait il y a 70 ans quand on
parle des Juifs dressz l'oreille c'est
de vous qu'on parle madame la Première
ministre cela fait 5 semaines que les
Françaises et les Français dressent
l'oreille ils sont inquiets ils sont
horrifiés ils sont scandalisé par la
résurgence de l'antisémitisme en France
pas un jour ne passe sans que notre pays
ne connaissent une nouvelle agression
une nouvelle menace une nouvelle
dégradation une nouvelle mise en cause
contre nos compatriotes de confession
juives cette réalité là nous scandalise
l'antisémitisme qui n'a jamais disparaî
de la société française redouble
d'acuité il s'étale sans complexe il
menace il SVIT il empoisonne la vie de
nos concitoyens de nos
compatriotes madame la Première ministre
toutes les forces politiques
républicaine et démocratique se mobilise
se dresse votre gouvernement aussi le
président du Sénat et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ont appelé à une
manifestation dimanche prochain c'est
une heureuse initiative merci monsieur
le
président madame la Première ministre
nous avons besoin de savoir aujourd'hui
quelle est la jeunesse de ces fait quels
moyens sont mobilisés quelle est la
volonté du gouvernement afin de lutter
contre la résurgence de l'antisémitisme
afin que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
prenne sa part toute sa part et sa juste
part contre ce
fléo pondre la parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le le
Président comme je l'ai répondu tout à
l'heure à la question de notre collègue
monsieur delè c'est plus de 11000
policiers gendarmes mobilisés avec les
militaires de sentinelle pour 950 sites
où les Français de confession juives ont
l'habitude de se
rendre il y a eu l'interdiction de
manifestation dans les heures dans les
jours qui ont suivi les attaques
terroristes islamistes du Hamas contre
les populations israéliennes qui ont
empêché il me semble que la France que
Paris n''est pas vécu ce qu'elle avait
soit vécu en 2013-24 où on a crié mort
au juifs dans les rues de Paris mais
aussi dans d'autres grand vill
européennes je pense à Berlin où on a
attaqué des synagogues à coup de
cocktail Molotof fort heureusement grâce
à la fermeté de l'État grâce à la
présence des policiers des gendarmes
cela n'est pas
arrivé vous posez la question de savoir
qui sont les personnes qui sont passées
à l'acte malheureusement je veux vous
dire qu'ils sont souvent très jeunes et
je dis au président de la commission des
lois de votre assemblée je suis tout à
fait prêt à répondre à à une commission
qui pourrait m'interroger sur la
sociologie de ces personnes 120
personnes d'origine 120 personnes pardon
étrangère dont une quarantaine
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
trois fichiers s parmi les 120 personnes
que j'évoque et sur les quasiment 500
interpellations une moyenne d'âge très
jeune pour ne pas dire très très jeune
souvent des mineurs comme ceux que l'on
a vu malheureusement chanter des
champnasis et de ha aux Juifs dans le
métro parisien identifié par la
préfecture de police et Don l'enquête
m'empêche de dire mais évidemment les
choses sont suivies très
particulièrement chaque acte antisémite
sur Internet chaque acte antisémite dans
le monde physique fait l'ouverture d'une
procédure judiciaire et met des services
de police techniqu et scientifiqu
partout sur le territoire national y
compris pour un graffiti qui veut dire
bien d'autres choses souvent le passage
à l'acte et je sais que la sévérité de
la justice accompagnera tous ceux qui
menacent de mort notamment des rabins ou
des personnes qui sont sensibles pour la
communauté je pense à l Valois peré
monsieur le ministre carucci où la
police en moins de 20 minutes a su
arrêter avec la plateforme TikTok la
personne la présenté de la justice est
déféré je voudrais simplement dire
monsieur le Président quelques instants
que la haine elle est avant tout sur les
plateformes et nous avons tous à
réfléchir également sur notre accès à
ces plateformes quand 75 % des contenus
antisémites signalés à la police
viennent de Twitter le ministre de
l'Intérieur se dit que les policiers ne
peut pas tout faire tout le monde doit
prendre sa
[Musique]
part
merci merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Première ministre je
crois pouvoir vous dire que sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée quels que
soient les groupes politiques vous nous
trouverez toujours mobilisés à vos côté
dès dimanche prochain et pour l'avenir
parce que nous sommes tous et toutes
dépositaires de cette phrase qui
circulait il y a quelques décennies en
France et en Europe et dans le monde
heureux comme un juif en France cette
phrase là elle nous oblige pour
aujourd'hui et pour
[Applaudissements]
demain
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Barros pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre messieurs
mesames les membres du gouvernement
chers collègues la mort du jeune Naël 17
ans tué lors d'un contrôle routier par
le tir d'un policier a étaé le point de
départ de 8 jours d'émeutes en France
d'une rare intensité maire de la ville
de faos dans le valdoise pendant cette
tempête urbaine j'ai été comme beaucoup
d'autres élus de France témoin d'actes
de violence et de dégradation je salue
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre
police et gendarmerie des agents des
services publics des élus et des
citoyens pendant cette période 4 mois
après ces tragiques événements la
présentation du plan gouvernement était
très attendue madame la Première
ministre vous avez dévoiler vos
propositions il y a 2 semaines à
l'amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne j'y étais
et je peux vous assurer que de nombreux
élus sont ressortis déçus vos
propositions restent largement
insuffisantes pour répondre aux enjeux
de nos territoires votre plan mêle à la
fois le tour répressif le contrôle
social et s'impose-elle une double peine
pour les familles notamment
monoparentales madame la Première
ministre avez-vous bien entendu ce que
demandent les élus locaux ne pensez-vous
pas que si les communes ont développé
des polices municipales et demandent
aujourd'hui leur armement c'est tout
simplement que les forces de l'ordre ont
purement et simplement disparu de leur
territoire ne pensez-vous pas que le
triptique prévention répression
insertion gagnerait à ce que l'État
assume clairement ses compét régalienne
lié au maintien de l'ordre public à ce
sujet que proposez-vous pour la
prévention spécialisée si utile dans nos
quartier pour terminer madame la
Première ministre quand on parle de de
police de proximité on parle de
complémentarité il faut accroître les
effectifs de police et de gendarmerie
nationale sur nos territoire mais il
faut aussi reconnaître le métier de
policier municipal pour ce qu'il est par
une rémunération et une évolution de
carrière à la hauteur de leur engagement
madame la Première ministre
prendrez-vous les moyens de cette
ambition pour vous répondre la parole
est madame la secrétaire d'État en
charge de la citoyenneté de la ville
madame agristi roubach vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur Pierre
Barros plusieurs réponse à votre vaste
question mais juste une précision la
Prévention Spécialisée il me semble bien
que ce sont les départements mais des
mesures ont été faites donc vous
m'interroger sur les réponses apportées
par le gouvernement aux émeutes urbaines
d'abord il y a eu et vous faites bien de
le rappeler les les actions immédiates
de gestion de crise pour établir l'ordre
républicain et c'est ce qui a été fait
avec la mobilisation de moyens
exceptionnels par le ministre de de
l'intérieur des mesures fortes ont été
ensuite prises pour favoriser la
reconstruction avec un projet de loi
dédié tout à fait transpartisant à
l'Assemblée nationale en parallèle
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement a
pris le temps du diagnostic et de la
concertation avec les élus locaux et les
acteurs de terrain sur des solutions à
apporter puis le 26 octobre la première
ministre a annoncé un ensemble de
mesures fortes qui concne toutes les
dimensions de l'action publique et pas
seulement la sécurité pourant en citer
que trois je commencerai par les forces
d'action républicaines qui ont pour
objectif de renforcer tous les services
publics vous le savez je l'avais dit
plusieurs fois je suis très attaché au
droits commun dans les quartiers
prioritaires simultanément sur tout le
territoire trois de ces phares seront
déployés à titre expérimental parce que
je pense que c'est le moment où jamais
d'expérimenter des choses comme on
pourrait dire on a tout essayé sauf qui
marche donc c'est peut-être le moment
Besançon Valence maug de plus la
responsabilisation des parents est un
enjeu majeur nous souhaitons créer une
contribution citoyenne en cas
d'infraction commise par un mineur
celle-ci participera également à
l'indemnisation des victimes parce qu'on
parle souvent trop peu des victimes
aussi à mon sens pour renforcer
l'encadrement des jeunes délinquants ou
décrocheurs nous développerons également
des dispositifs visants à leur insertion
dans une vie citoyenne et active comme
les classes de défense ou le service
militaire volontaire enfin concernant
l'usage des réseaux sociaux qui vous le
savez ont jouer un rôle de catalyseur
dans ces émeutes nous créerons une peine
complémentaire de suspension de comptes
utilisateur en cas d'infraction commise
sur une plateforme en ligne il s'agit
donc d'une réponse multiforme ça serait
trop long de d'énumérer tout ce qui a
été dit et annoncé au CIV mais oui le
gouvernement déploie en tout cas sous
l'autorité de la première ministre en en
mobilisant pardon tous les lier
disponible pour que ces événements ne se
ne se reproduisent plus monsieur le
sénateur et on pourrait aussi en
discuter parce que les les
mesures merci Monsieur Merci becoup vous
avez quelques
secondes oui en effet on a lu les
comités de presse on ce qui est dans
dans les communiqué moi peut-être que
force d'expérimentation ce serait bien
que à titre expérimental l'état fa son
travail ce sera déjà pas
mal est à notre collègue Olivier pour le
groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je veux évoquer ici ce qu'on
appellera peut-être demain l'affaire
villemotte stéphane vilmotte est maire
d'une commune du nord au monont qui a vu
l'expulsion d'un imam salafiste à la
suite de son courage et puis de la
volonté du du Préfet et du ministre
c'était on ne peut plus normal puisqu'il
faisait des prêches d'apologie du
terrorisme mais aussi de remise en cause
de notre notre modèle républicain il est
aujourd'hui en Algérie alors ça aurait
pu s'arrêter là mais seulement demain
Stéphane vilmotte à la suite d'une
citation directe de ce triste individu
sera devant le tribunal alors il s'agit
pas pour moi de faire une quelconque
pression sur la justice elle est
souveraine naturellement mais de poser
quelques questions légitimes première
question est-ce que c'est opportun
est-ce qu'ilut poser la question de
modifier la législation et c'est le sens
de l'amendement que nous avons déposé
avec Stéphane demilli j'ai des doutes
sur la question mais vous y répondraz
faut-il renforcer l'accompagnement et et
l'aide des préfets et des procureurs sur
les maires par rapport à cette question
faut-il prolonger le délai d'enquête
enfin toutes ces questions se posent
mais ma conviction notre conviction elle
est la suivante il faut absolument ne
pas laisser les maires seuls ses
soutiers de de la République face à
cette question des mariages de
complaisance qui risque de se multiplier
au moment même où nous renforçons à
juste titre et légitimement les
questions liées au au droits des
étrangers je vous remercie pr la parole
est au ministre de
l'Intérieur merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur h je veux d'abord après vous
souigner le courage de Stéphane vmol le
maire de haond dans le Nord qui grâce à
ses informations à son action dans cette
petite commune par ailleurs charmante
mais qui a peu de moyens à interpeller
le préfet du Nord vous-même et et
moi-même pour pouvoir expulser cet imam
étranger qui exposait une version de
l'islam moyenageuse radicale
insupportable et oui nous avons réussi
grâce à l'lection du préfet du Nord à
l'expulser et il n'est plus sur le
territoire national avec une
interdiction de retour sur le territoire
national vous avez raison de dire
monsieur le sénateur que par ailleurs
monsieur vilmot paye cher pour lui et
pour sa vie personnelle celle de sa
famille son courage et d'abord il a
l'entière soutien l'entier soutien bien
sûr de la République du ministre de
l'intérieur des services puisque
plusieurs fois j'ai échangé avec lui et
sa protection bien évidemment physique
lorsqu'il a été menacé je crois que vous
avez parfaitement raison sur les
enquêtes qui doivent durer plus
longtemps sans doute pour permettre à un
maire ou un officier d'état civil
lorsqu'il agit en délégation notamment
de l'État en l'occurrence des services
de la justice lorsqu'il a un doute
lorsqu'il a un doute pour la véracité de
ce mariage et même si un étranger en
situation irrégulière c'est
constitutionnel a le droit de se marier
sur le territoire national en aucun cas
en aucun cas ça ne fait obstacle à son
éloignement ça a été le cas évidemment
pour le cas évoqué aussi à la mairie de
Bézier où bien sûr cette personne a été
expulsée malgré le fait que le procureur
de la République a demandé au maire de
bzier de faire ce ce mariage il y a donc
monsieur le sénateur à réfléchir sans
doute dans le cadre de laimmigration
puisque nous avons adopté hier soir
amendement de Monsieur bit sur la
reconnaissance fruduleuse de documents
et notamment de paternité passant à
délit de 5 ans et à une peine de plus de
75000 demande il y a donc à réfléchir et
nous sommes en train d'y réfléchir donc
n'hésitons pas à y travailler ensemble
soit au Sénat soit à la navette soit
dans la CMP pour permettre au maire de
décider vraiment lorsqu'il a un doute
sérieux est-ce que ces services lui ont
permis comme c'est le cas de Monsieur
vinmot de le documenter de s'opposer à
un mariage lorsque les gens ne veulent
pas se marier par amour mais par intérêt
contre la
République
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse merci d'avoir souligné le le
courage de Monsieur vilmotte Merci de la
volonté de l'État enfin en tous les cas
on a un devoir c'est de ne pas laisser
les maires seul parce que je pense que
ce cas n'est pas un cas unique et qu'il
risque de se multiplier par rapport à
les tentatives ou tentations de mariage
de complaisance je vous remercie si la
parole est maintenant au
président groupe les
républicain
monsieur monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre madame la Première
ministre nous sommes entrés dans une
aire où la compétition stratégique entre
les puissances et désormais la norme et
où la lutte contre les ingérences
étrangères est devenue une préoccupation
de chaque
instant la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement on a d'ailleurs fait le
thème central de son dernier rapport son
président rapporteur Sacha Houlier
membre de votre majorité
il propose un plan d'action pour
protéger les intérêts économiques et
scientifiques de notre pays en résumé il
vous invite à sortir du dénis c'est un
vœ similaire que nous formulions le 2
août dernier avec mes collègues les
républicains dans une tribune intitulé
cessons de vendre nos fleurons les plus
stratégiques à des puissances étrangères
nous alertions sur la décision d'Athos
de céder une partie de son groupe la
société épit investment propriété du
milliardche Daniel kranssk depuis cette
publication dans colonne du Figaro pas
une semaine sans un nouveau
rebondissement chute vertigineuse du
cours d'Atos frontte des actionnaires
plainte déposé au PNF départ forcé du
président d'Atos ou encore cette semaine
une arrivée très opportune d'un nouvel
investisseur bien sûr atos est une
entreprise privée mais elle n'est pas
une entreprise comme les autres c'est
sur elle et sur ces super calculateurs
que repose une partie de notre
souveraineté nucléaire son démantèlement
et surtout l'imixion d'acteurs étrangers
fustil européens font peser un risque
INAC
alors que l'enjeu est crucial comment
peut-on comprendre le silence
assourdissant de votre gouvernement sur
cette question madame la Première
ministre reprenez les choses en main le
projet de Monsieur kranssk fera-t-il oui
ou non l'objet d'un contrôle au titre
des investissements étrangers en France
nous attendons une réponse
[Applaudissements]
claire la parole
minlégé numque monsieur
bar
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cédric Perin vous avez raison
de le dire Athos n'est pas une
entreprise comme les autres c'est un
fleuron industriel français plus de
100000 emplois une présence dans plus de
70 pays et grâce à cette entreprise
depuis plus de 20 ans des savoir-faes
technologiques français qui rayonnent
dans le monde entier et il est vrai que
pour une part certes minoritair de ces
activités Athos représente intérêt
stratégique pour la souveraineté
numérique de notre pays je pense
évidemment au super calcul puisque Atos
c'est la dernière entreprise européenne
à savoir concevoir et produire des super
calculateurs je pense à la cybersécurité
et à la cyberdéfense en rappelant
qu'Atos est le partenaire premier des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour la
cyber sécurité et je pense évidemment
vous l'avez dit à la supervision de
notre parc nucléaire cependant
contrairement à ce qui a été proposé
notamment à l'Assemblée nationale et
comme l'a rappelé le ministre de
l'économie et des finances ce matin le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à la
nationalisation d'Atos parce qu'une
telle décision ne règlerait pas les
problèmes opérationnels et financiers de
l'entreprise et parce que ce n'est pas
de la tutelle de l'État qu'Atos a besoin
mais bien d'investisseurs et de
partenaires industriels ceci étant dit
et pour vous rassurer euh il faut
d'abord rappeler que une prise de
participation en dessous de 10 % euh ne
confère à celui qui s'y adonne qu'un
qu'une influence très marginale sur la
vie de l'entreprise et que par ailleurs
et que par ailleurs nous n'hésiterons
pas à activer le contrôle des
investissements étrangers en France
comme vous le savez monsieur le sénateur
le code monétaire et financier soumet
toute prise de participation par un
acteur étranger d'une entreprise
d'importance stratégique en France à une
autoritisation du ministre de l'économie
et des finances soyez assurés que sous
l'autorité de la première ministre le
gouvernement est attentif à l'avenir
d'Athos et à la garantie de la
souveraineté numérique de la
France Merci Merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse ceux qui comme moi
attendaient une réponse claire en sont
pour leur frais
et dans ce contexte l'absence de réponse
à ma question obligera le Sénat à
exercer son devoir constitutionnel de
contrôle et donc en apport avec la
commission des affaires économiques la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense exercera son devoir de
contrôle sur
lafferatos
par est au président canner pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre depuis la
mise en place de l'Ame aide médicale
d'État par lun Jospin en 99 les
détracteurs de cette mesure sont
toujours les mêmes l'extrême droite les
extrêmes droites de Le Pen
àzemour hier soir le Sénat a voté sa
suppression sans opposition de votre
gouvernement c'est une digue de plus qui
vient de sauter cette suppression s'est
faite sur un fond de cacophonie
gouvernementale le 7 octobre le ministre
dararmanin se déclarait pour la
suppression de la me ce lundi vous avez
déclaré y être défavorable laame étant
je vous cite un enjeu d'humanité et de
santé publique et ce dans la du rapport
stéphanini Evin ce mardi ici même après
un plaéidoyer émouvant presque pour
l'ame après avoir indiquer l'attachement
du Gouvernement à ce dispositif et
marquer son opposition à la droite
sénatoriale la ministre firmain le
baudau s'est totalement dédite en
émettant un avis de sagesse synonyme de
blancin pour cette même droite
sénatoriale le soir même son ministre de
tutelle Aurélien Rousseau l'a désavoué
en regrettant cette suppression qu'il
qualifiait de grave erreur
nous partageons l'avis de votre Ministre
le
dernier nous nous élevons contre cette
posture politicienne de la droite
sénatoriale prête à sacrifier la santé
des étrangers et les enjeux de santé
publique dans un calcul électoral
cynique l'ensemble du corps médical est
révolté nos hôpitaux s'en trouvent
fragilisés une certaine idée de la
République sociale est bafouée madame la
Première ministre à quelques heures de
la prévisible suppression des article 3
et 4 du projet de loi nous n'y
comprenons plus rien sauf à constater la
recomposition de la droite avec votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur à la manœuvre en
conséquence madame le première ministre
quelle est la position officielle de
votre gouvernement sur le devenir de
laame répondre la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Patrick canner vous avez entamé
lundi l'examen du projet de loi
immigration porté par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Géral d'armanin alors vous
le savez ce projet répond à un double
objectif d'une part éloigner plus
rapidement ce qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester sur notre sol et d'autre part
mieux intégrer ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir
alors vous m'interrogez spécifiquement
sur
l'ame ma position est sans ambigué c'est
celle de mon gouvernement qui a été
exprimé très clairement
hier
l'ame
l'ame l'ame est un dispositif la me est
un dispositif nécessaire qui répond à un
impératif de santé publique il doit
permettre de soigner les personnes
malades qui sont sur notre sol et par
ailleurs l'ame est aussi une protection
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens car
elle permet de prévenir la propagation
de certaines maladies la PR
[Applaudissements]
charge la prise en charge au plutôt des
infections respiratoires des hépatites
ou du VI IH par exemple est une
nécessité je veux ensuite le souligner
l'ame est un dispositif très encadré et
surveillé c'est même le dispositif le
plus contrôlé de l'Assurance
Maladie pour débattre de ce sujet nous
avons besoin d'un diagnostic précis
objectif et actualisé c'est l'objet de
la mission confiée à Patrick stéphanini
et cl des vin par le ministre de
l'Intérieur le ministre de la santé et
la ministre délégué la ministre a eu
l'occasion de vous le dire hier lors de
vos débats cet état des lieux de la
situation est indispensable il permettra
le cas échéant de proposer des
évolutions pour la me nous attendons les
conclusions de la mission d'ici début
décembre elles seront naturellement
rendu publiques et le gouvernement en
tirera les conséquences dans la suite du
débat parlementaire mais je veux le
rappeler la me a déjà été réformé en
2019 dans le cadre naturel qui est le
projet doit de financement de la
sécurité sociale monsieur le Président
canner ma méthode est constante les
faits le débat la recherche d'efficacité
c'est l'inverse même du dogmatisme et
des postures cette méthode c'est celle
de mon Gouvernement sur ce texte comme
sur les autres je vous
remerciere collègue Françoise
lumont pour le groupe les
républicains
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adressa à monsieur le garde des saau
ministre de la Justice monsieur le
ministre le 27 octobre dernier les
journalistes de RMC ont dévoiler des
éléments du rapport ignpn IgA igj sur la
gestion des stocks de procédures
présenté au gouvernement en juin 2023 ce
rapport que j'ai à plusieurs reprises
auprès de vos services et de ceux du
garde des saau demandé à pouvoir
consulé n'a pas été rendu public
pourtant des journalistes ont pu s'en
procurer un exemplaire dans ce document
il serait indiquer que l'année dernière
les commissariats disposaient d'un stock
ancien de 2,7 millions de plaines dont
un tiers serait en stock depuis plus de
2 ans auquel il faut ajouter 3 millions
et demi de nouvelles plaintes
enregistrées dans le courant de l'année
il est ainsi indiqué qu'en moyenne un
policier doit traiter 180 dossiers par
an et pour les les les enquêteurs les
plus spécialisés on parle de 800
dossiers par an le rapport préciserait
ainsi je cite des dossiers portant sur
des faits graves dorment dans certains
services sans avoir fait l'objet
d'investigation alors même que les les
auteurs présumés ont été identifié et le
rapport de conclure qu'en l'absence de
mesures correctrices et à délinquence
équivalente le stock de procédure
pourrait continue à augmenter d'ici 2030
passer à 3 millions et demi de plaintes
en attente dans un état de droit il
n'est pas possible de laisser des
coupables dehors en toute impunité dans
un état de droit il n'est pas possible
de ne pas répondre au devoir de justice
vis-à-vis des victimes aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pourriez-vous nous préciser si
cela est lié à une question de manque
d'effectif pourriez-vous nous préciser
quelles sont les 17 recommandations de
ce rapport et si le Gouvernement entend
y donner suite et quand et enfin et
surtout monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous assurer devant la représentation
nationale que que l'ensemble des
dossiers seront bien traités avant la
fin des délais de prescription des
éventuels actes passibles de sanction
pénal visé par les quelques 2,7 millions
de Dossi en souffrance je vous
remercieondre la parole ministre de
l'Intérieur merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice c'est justement
parce que nous avons conscience avec le
garde des saut des grandes difficultés
notamment de la filière dite
investigation au sein des forces de
l'ordre que nous avons commandé en effet
les inspections de nos deux ministères
un état des lieux que nous rendrons
public bien sûr et notamment en premier
lieu la représentation nationale il y a
en effet un petit peu moins de 3
millions de procédures de plainte qui ne
sont pas en ce moment suivies je
rappelle quand même que ces 5 millions
si on fait police et gendarmerie de
plaintes qui sont déposées par an il y a
donc évidemment énormément de dépôt de
plaintte fait par nos compatriotes pour
de toute forme de raison qu' soi
évidemment des choses extrêmement graves
qui touchent les atteintes physiques ou
des les choses matérielles qui sont
évidemment tout aussi graves qui
méritent une réponse mais qui ne sont
pas évidemment de la même urgence pour
quels sont les problèmes et pourquoi il
y a eu ce stock et pourquoi il y a ce
stock de procédure d'abord il faut bien
le voir madame la sénatrice c'est en
effet un manque chronique de policiers
et de gendarmes nous en avons rajouté
grâce à vous puisque vous avez voté ces
texte 17000 dans la grande majorité faut
dire que nous réparions beaucoup
d'erreurs 17000 policiers et gendarmes
de plus mais nous ne pouvons pas créer
exnilo des officiers de police Judici le
ministintérieur ne peut pas affecter les
OPJ on doit d'abord les former et la
dernière loi de programmation que j'ai
fait voter que vous avez suivi permet de
créer les OPJ dès l'école de police ce
qui nous permet dès cette année
d'envoyer désormais dans les
commissariats des jeunes OPJ et non pas
d'attendre le moment où il passe
exactement ce concours de PJ
deuxièmement une simplification de la
procédure pénale évidemment puisqu'il y
a deux cadres d'enquête l'une qui
consiste évidemment à la flagrance
l'autre à la préliminaire le garde des
saut a fait voter un texte ici qui
prévoit la simplification cette
procédure auquelle vous allez y
travailler la numérisation puisque
toutes les les procédures étaient papier
lorsque je suis arrivé il y a 3 ans au
ministère de l'intérieur c'est plus que
50 % du cas aujourd'hui comme la pour à
la source la police doit se moderniser
les moyens auprès des parquets ou des
greffes puisque évidemment les policiers
font le travail sous l'autorité des
parquets et des greffes les moyens ont
été évoqués lors de la dernière loi
justice et puis bien sûr madame la la la
la sénatrice il est tout à fait évident
que nous allons traiter l'ensemble des
procédures il n'y aura pas d' de
prescription lorsque les plaintes ont
été déposé et j'ai donné comme consigne
que l'on commence en renforçant
d'illeurs les effectifs à à toucher en
premier ce qu'on fait des atteintes au
bien et aux personnes pardon et
notamment ce qui touche les femmes et
les enfants merci la parole est notre
collègue Vincent delay pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le 22 mars dernier le ministre
de l'économie et des finances annonçait
publiquement son intention d'interroger
le Conseil d'État sur sur une un
possible raccourcissement des de la
durée des contrats de concession
d'autoroute le 8 juin le Conseil d'État
rendait son avis entre ces deux dates 22
mars et 8 juin est-il exact monsieur le
ministre que qu'un contentieux aurait
été entamé par les sociétés d'autoroute
pour atteinte à leur
image pensez-vous que ce contentieux a
pu avoir un effet et un impact sur la
vie du Conseil d'État et 3ème question
le Sénat a réclamé un som des autoroutes
ce sommet des autoroutes a été main de
fois repoussé malheureusement souvent
annoncé j'aimerais savoir quand il aura
lieu la paroleist délégé chargé des
transports Monsieur
B merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de la chacun connaît ici votre
intérêt votre expertise et si j'ose dire
votre passion pour la question
autoroutière de longue date alors alors
pour reprendre la chronologie des faits
très précisément en effet avec Bruno
Lemer nous avons annoncé devant
l'Assemblée nationale au mois de mars de
manière tout à fait transparente que
nous allions saisir le Conseil d'État
pour être tout à fait complet sur deux
points l'un qui est celui que vous avez
rappelé la possibilité la question de la
durée des concessions pour les contrats
en cours serait-il possible d'un point
de vue juridique et évidemment sans une
compensation massive ou significative de
changer ou de raccourcir la durée des
concessions 2è question très importante
puisqu'elle sera soumise prochainement
dans le cadre du budget pour 2024 à
votre assemblée celle de euh la
compensation ou plutôt la taxation la
contribution des sociétés autoroutières
notamment à la stratégie de
décarbonation à notre plan
d'investissement pour les transports sur
le premier point comme sur l'ensemble de
ces questions je suppose en effet les
sociétés d'autoroute ont déposé un
contentieux je n'ai pas le commenter
nous sommes en état de droit c'est leur
droit je pense que il n'y a un un seul
cas dans lequel un contentieux pourrait
avoir un effet sur la saisine du Conseil
d'État sur le plan consultatif dans le
respect de nos règles c'est si le
Conseil d'État lui-même estimait que les
deux questions étaient suffisamment
proches pour suspendre les travaux l'un
de l'autre ce ne fut pas le cas le
Conseil d'État n'a pas décidé de
suspendre ses travaux consultatifs et a
rendu un avis que nous avons décidé avec
la première ministre de rendre publique
rapidement dès la fin de l'été sur ces
deux questions d'ailleurs donc pour être
très clair je ne pense qu'en aucun cas
le contentieux qui est un droit sur un
point spécifique soulevé par les
sociétés d'autoroute a pu influer d'une
quelconque façon sur l'indépendance du
Conseil d'État dans sa fonction
consultative et le respect des règles a
été entièrement assuré si vous faites
état d'une quelconque pression qui
pourrait être exercé ça ne marche pas
puisque nous avons décidé sur le deuxè
point de saisir l'Assemblée nationale
comme le Sénat dans le cadre du PLF 2024
d'une contribution des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute quant à
l'avenir des concessions je ne sais pas
ce sera un sommet mais en effet nous
lancerons d'ici la fin de l'année ces
travaux associant le Sénat comme
l'Assemblée nationale pour travailler à
l'avenir de nos concessions
autoroutières Monsieur
delae Merci monsieur le ministre pour
ces précisions c'est pas les
informations que j'avais hein il me
semblait que le Conseil d'État a été
influencé par le fait qu'il y ait eu un
recours donc écoutez je je prends acte
de vos déclarations euh je serais
sensible au fait que l'on puisse
effectivement tenir peut-être pas un
sommet euh le le nom m'importe peu
l'important c'est qu'on puisse dialoguer
qu'on puisse dialoguer avec vous mais
qu'on puisse dialoguer aussi avec les
sociétés d'autoroute qui ne sont pas
très ouvertes au dialogue et que on
puisse regarder quel est l'équilibre
financier de ces contrats vous savez que
nous considérons qu'il est beaucoup ils
sont beaucoup trop profitables et que
ces contrats sont pas adaptés à des
vraies concessions et que il prévoi
notamment des augmentations de tarifs
qui sont lié à l'inflation alors que le
résultats des sociétés d'autoroute et
leurs charges sont assez peu lié à
l'inflation donc moi je vous demande
aussi de faire attention
à l'augmentation qui va être annoncée
pour 2024 l'augmentation 2023 de 475 % a
été très importante elle permet d'ici la
fin des contrats aux autoroutes aux
sociétés d'autoroutes de faire 4
milliards d'euros de bénéfices
supplémentair donc je pense qu'il faut
faire très très attention à ces
augmentation je compte sur vous pour
être vigilant et pour montrer que dans
une concession le patron c'est
l'état la parole est à notre collègue
marieoleu pour le groupe
républain monsieur monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des saau dont nous
regrettons l'absence un maire et sa
famille ciblé avec une tentative
d'incendie à leur domicile la h rose
deux mairies intégralement brûlées à
villeneuve-leroi et à Valenton plusieurs
postes de police municipal attaqué dont
ceux de villecine et de Suiss enri pour
ne parler que de mon seul départ ement
le valdearne a payé un très lourd tribut
aux émeutes pourtant 4 mois plus tard
s'il y a eu trois personnes condamnées
pour le poste de police municipale de
vicraine il n'y a eu à ma connaissance
aucune autre suite judiciaire pas même à
la hî et rose les émeutes qui se sont
déroulé dans notre pays ont occasionné
d'après les assureurs 650 millions
d'euros de dégâts avec un millier de
bâtiments publics touchés ce sont les
symboles de notre République qui ont été
visés élus mairie école commissariat
police municipale lors de la réunion à
la Sorbonne le 26 octobre madame la
Première ministre a insisté sur une
réponse pénale exemplaire et le refus
total de l'impunité objectif auquel je
ne peux que souscrire selon les chiffres
communiqués par le gouvernement au cours
de l'été il y a eu 1000 condamnations
principalement à de courtes peine pour
10000 émetiers mais où en est-on
aujourd'hui la représentation nationale
est en droit de disposer d'un bilan
département par département du nombre
nbre de personnes interpellé du nombre
de personnes condamnées avec le détail
des peines et leur exécution le garde
des saut peut-il nous confirmer que tous
les moyens de l'État sont encore
mobilisés pour mener les enquêtes
sanctionner les vrais coupables et
donneurs d'ordre de toutes les atteintes
grave aux personnes et aux bien
perpétrés durant quelques jours il en va
de la crédibilité de l'État et de Sal
des
élus pour vous répondre la parole est à
la secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville vous avez la
parole madame merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice sur la
période du 27 juin au 7 juillet 2023 66
départements et 516 communes ont été le
théâtre de violen urbaines le 30 juin
2023 le gardessau a adressé une
circulaire aux procureurs généraux et
procureurs de la République afin qu'une
réponse pénale rapide ferme et
systématique soit adressé à l'encontre
des auteurs de ces exactions le
traitement judiciaire a été effectif et
empreint de célérité
un taux de réponse pénale de 92 % un
taux de poursuite par déferement de 90 %
le recours à la comparution immédiate a
été massif représentant 60 % des
poursuites devant le tribunal
correctionnel près de 1800 personnes ont
été condamnées à une peine
d'emprisonnement dans le contum de peine
moyenne avoisine les 9 mois de prison
ferme le ministre de la Justice porte
actuellement 12 mesures concrètes visant
à renforcer la répressionvers les plus
jeunes et à responsabiliser leurs
parents parmi celle-ci la création de
placement le pardon parmi ceci la
création d'un placement éducatif de jour
ou de nuit pour les mineurs dont
l'irrespect entraînera son placement en
centre éducatif fermé ou en détention
provisoire un partenariat renforcé avec
l'armée pour suivre certains mineurs
délinquants la création d'une
responsabilité civile de plein droit
pour les deux parents de mineurs même
s'ils sont séparés
ou encore l'aggravation du délit de
soustraction d'un parent à ses
obligations légales envers son envers
son enfant voilà quelques mesures assez
fortes qui ont été salué il me semble
par pas mal d'élus et le gardess saau
viendra quand il le pourra vous répondre
plus précisément je vous remercie Mame
CHU pour pour le maire de la hérose qui
nous écoute aujourd'hui je pense que
l'espoir d'une sanction de ces
agresseurs s'éloignent encore c'est vrai
que c'était pas comme s'il n'avait pas
eu de votre part madame la min la
première ministre quand vous êtes venu
le voir l'assurance que ces agresseurs
seraient sanctionnés on l'espère
[Applaudissements]
sincèrement est à notre collègue Simon
usen pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain madame la Première ministre
la tempête carane a très durement
éprouvé la Bretagne il faut tout d'abord
saluer l'engagement exceptionnel des
pompiers des forces de l'ordre et de
sécurité civile des agents des
collectivités territorial et des
opérateurs en particulier d'énédis
honorons la mémoire des victimes et
rendons hommage à Frédéric Despo agent
d'énédis décédé dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions nos pensées vont vers sa
famille et ses collègues éplorés le
monde agricole est très lourdement
impacté la réunion du comité catastrophe
naturelle est annoncée le 14 novembre 2
semaines après le début de la tempête
c'est bien tard il s'agit d'une promesse
du président et de votre gouvernement
hier devant l'Assemblée nationale mais
depuis nous avons eu confirmation que
les dégâts provoqués par la tempête
n'entrait pas dans ce champ de garantie
qu'en est-il précisément sur
l'approvisionnement en électricité quand
vous citez quelques pourcent de foyers à
raccorder au moment où l'on se parle il
s'agite en réalité de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de bretonnes et de Bretons
qui n'en peuvent plus des promesses non
tenues de très nombrebreuses
défaillances nous sont remonté tous les
jours pas de téléphone satellitair
fournis par les préfectures et des élus
contraints d'improviser un réseau sibi
en Finistère une usine d'eau potable
dépriorisée dans les Côtes d'Armor une
station d'épuration sans électricité
dans le morbillant et un maire obligé
d'appeler le copain d'un copain chez
enedis faute de coordonnées transmises
en amont des élus contraints d'utiliser
leurs véhicules pour aller chercher des
groupes électrogène qui arrivait en
Bretagne 3 jours après le début de la
tempête un maire obligé de faire six
relances différentes en 6 jours pour
mettre en sécurité deux points critiques
perdu au milieu de nulle part pour
reprendre leur mots obligés d'endosser
des responsabilités majeures sans les
bonnes informations et sans les moyens
appropriés les maires et les élus sont à
bout la sous-traitance de l'État confine
des désormais à la maltraitance nous
voyons là les effets directs du
désarmement de nos services publics du
sous-investissement chronique et de la
logique de flutendu qui ne nous
permettent pas de faire face aux
épreuves d'un monde qui se dérègle face
à la multiplication prévisible des
catastrophes climatiques il y a urgence
à agir quelles actions concrète
allez-vous mettre en œuvre pour que ces
situations ne se reproduisent plus pour
la parole est à la ministre délégué dans
char des collectivité
territoriale merci monsieur le Président
mesames etessieurs sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hena alors je rappelle tout
d'abord que les dommages causés par les
vents violent sont couverts par la
garantie tempête des polices d'assurance
souscrit par les collectivités en vertu
de l'article L 122-7 du Code des
Assurances par ailleurs vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le sénateur le
président de la République en
déplacement dans le Finistère ce
vendredi 3 novembre a indiqué que l'état
de catastrophe naturelle et celui de
calamité agricoes seront déclenchés très
vite sur ce sujet La Réunion comité
catastrophe naturelle se tiendra le 14
novembre vous trouvez que c'est un peu
long c'est quand même très rapide
monsieur le sénateur le décret paraîtra
dans les jours qui suivent ce mécanisme
bénéficiera bien sûr aux collectivités
territoriales et permettra notamment de
couvrir les dommages liés au phénomène
de submersion ou de débordement des
cours d'eau s'il devait y avoir des
difficultés avec les assureurs pour
assurer le remboursement des dommages
nous ferons le nécessaire avec le
Médiateur des assurances dont vous savez
qu'il peut depuis le mois de septembre
être saisi par les collec activité
elle-même nous disposons enfin de la
dotation de solidarité qui permet dans
de tels cas de prendre en charge les
dégâts subis par les bien des
collectivités j'ai demandé la semaine
dernière à la DGCL d'adresser au préfet
concernés un message leur rappelant les
conditions d'engagement de cette
dotation de façon à ce que les prises en
charge puissent être rapides et
significatives j'y veillerai
personnellement par ailleurs le ministre
de l'Agriculture poursuit les travaux
d'évaluation des dégâts afin
d'enclencher toutes les procédures de
reconnaissance en calamité Agri école
dans les délais les plus courts
s'agissant des pertes de récoltes
celles-ci seront prises en charge dans
le cadre du nouveau système assuranciel
y compris pour les agriculteurs non
assurés via l'indemnité de solidarité
nationale comme à chaque fois nous
serons bien entendu au côtés des
collectivités des agriculteurs et de
tous nos concitoyens je vous remercie la
parole est à notre collègue agès Evren
pour le groupe les
républicains ma question ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale dès votre prise de fonction et
il y a encore quelques jours vous avez
prononcé des mots forts contre le
harcèlement votre position a été
courageuse parents enseignant et
victimes tous avaient besoin d'entendre
ce message clair
l'omerta était devenu insupportable les
chiffres publiés hier par l'Ifop pour
l'association Marion la maintendue sont
accablants un jeune sur 5 est victime de
harcèlement scolaire c'était auparavant
1/ 10 et la moitié des victimes n'en
parl pas près de 80 % des parents se
disent inquiets il y a urgence les faits
je le rappelle sont sans précédent avant
le harcèlement scolaire s'arrêtait au
grilles de l'école à 16h30 aujourd'hui
il se répand H24 sur les réseaux sociaux
avec TikTok insta ou snapchat qui par
leur viralité démultiplie les
conséquences dramatiques et ne la aucun
répit aux victimes vous avez monsieur le
ministre annoncé 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour la création de
brigad anti-harcèlement ces moyens
seront-ils suffisants alors que trop
d'établissements gèent la pénurie
pénurie de médecins scolaires pénuries
de psychologue scolaires pénurie
d'infirmière scolairire pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que tous les personnels seront
désormais systématiquement formés pour
prévenir et détecter allez-vous rendre
obligatoir les questionnaires
d'autoévaluation alors que les 2 heures
banalisées sont facultatives enfin en
matière de sanction pouvez-vous nous
préciser la mise en place des mesures
d'éloignement du harceleur pour protéger
la victime comme notre collègue Marie
Mercier l'avait proposé dans sa PPL
Cigné par 215 sénateurs de tous les bans
de cet hémicycle monsieur le ministre
face à ce drame humain considérable
l'action doit être à la hauteur de la
communication je vous
remercie la parole comministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur
Atal merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs monsieur les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice éen s'il
est une cause qui peut nous rassembler
par-dà l'éclivage politique je crois
profondément que c'est la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire ce fléo
absolument insupportable qui fait que
des élèves vont à l'école la boule au
ventre et parfois se donneent la mort
parce qu'ils subissent les brimades les
insultes les coups et je vous remercie
du caractère très constructif de votre
question et je vous confirme que pour
lutter contre ce fléo nous avons besoin
de toutes les bonnes idées et que le
groupe LR du Sénat apportter ces
dernières années des idées madame
Mercier l'a fait et d'autres et que ça
nous inspire évidemment dans notre
action vous m'avez posé trois questions
très concrètes la première sur la
formation oui nous généralisons le
programme phare qui fait que dans chaque
établissement scolaire vous devez avoir
au moins C adultes formés avec une vraie
formation sur la lutte contre le
harcèlement des enseignants des
personnels de vie scolaire d'autres
personnels aussi on s'est rendu compte
par exemple que former des agents de la
cantine c'était très utile parce qu'ils
voient beaucoup de choses et qu'ils
peuvent aussi détecter est signalé
deuxième chose sur le questionnaire
effectivement demain est une journée
importante chaque année il y a la
journée de lutte contre le harcèlement
les années précédente c'était autour
d'un tiers des établissements qui
organisaient une action cette année j'ai
décidé que tous les établissements
scolaires devront le faire et pour vous
répondre très concrètement les 2 heures
banalisées ne sont absolument pas une
option ça me permet de le rappeler que
d'avoir cette question la classe doit
s'arrêter pendant 2h dans tous les
établissements scolaires pour un débat
sur le harcèlement et ce questionnaire
d'autoévaluation que nous avons rédigé
avec Marcel ruffau Nicole Katheline Éric
de Barbieux troème question sur le
changement de règle je l'ai dit dès cet
été après ma nomination c'est au
harceleur de quitter l'établissement et
non plus au harceler et oui cette règle
s'applique je vous donne un exemple à
monmarsan un lycéen fait l'objet de
harcèlement depuis la rentrée scolaire
le 9 octobre il le signale au chefs
d'établissement qui l'accompagne dans le
dépôt d'une plainte une semaine plus
tard les trois élèves harceleurs âgés de
15 et 16 ans sont interpellés par les
forces de police en garde à vue ils
passeront devant le juge des enfant
enfant le 15 novembre et entre-temps ils
ont été exclus de l'établissement ce
sont plusieurs dizaines de jeunes
harceleurs qui ont été exclus de leur
établissement depuis que j'ai pris cette
décision la peur est en train de changer
de camp la honte est en train de changer
de camp évidemment il y a encore du
travail parce que ça ne s'applique pas
encore partout mais vous pouvez compter
sur ma mobilisation comme je sais
pouvoir compter sur la vôtre pour
[Applaudissements]
avancer je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre pour vos pour vos précisions je
rappelle que beaucoup d'annonces avaient
été faites notamment il y a quelques
années sur le respect de la laïcité à
l'école et que force de constater
aujourd'hui malheureusement que aussi
rarement le principe de laïcité a été
fragilisé j'ose espérer qu'il n'en sera
pas de même pour la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
dans le cadre aussi de l'examen du
projet de loi immigration en cours
l'article 72 78 aléa 2 du code de
procédure pénale prévoit que toute
personne peut-être contrôlé dans une
zone de 20 km en DESS de la frontière
terrestre de la France avec les états de
l'espace Schengen ainsi lorsquun
étranger arrive sans les documents
nécessaires pour son établissement en
France ou alors qu'il n' avait pas
l'autorisation il s'expose à un refus
d'entrée sur le territoire et peut-être
placé en zone d'attente le temps pour
l'administration d'organiser son retour
cette procédure de quelques heures
parfois jusqu'à 24 heures avait prouvé
jusqu'à aujourd'hui son efficacité
pourtant dans un arrêt récent du 21
septembre 2023 la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne estime que la France
ne peut pas procéder au refoulement vers
un pays voisin de personnes migrantes
entré illégalement sur le territoire
sans qu'il puisse bénéficier d'un
certain délai pour quitter
volontairement le territoire sur le
terrain cela va donc se traduire par la
mise en place d'une procédure
administrative de réadmission
nécessitant le respect de ce délai
allant à l'encontre du message de
fermeté et d'efficacité clamé par le
gouvernement et aussi par notre
assemblée nous avons donc affaire à une
décision de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne venant
court-circuiter le droit national et
parfois nos propres procédure
administrative et cela dans un contexte
où la gestion des flux migratoires est
très problématique je le constade dans
mon département les Hautes Alpes où les
migrants passent régulièrement entre
l'Italie et la France via notamment
l'école de l'échelle ou de Mont-Genèvre
malheureusement ni l'accueil de migrant
ni la frontière frontalière ne sont à la
hauteur de nos exigences démocratiques
monsieur le ministre comment l'État va
prendre en compte la décision de la Cour
européenne dans ce contexte de politique
migratoire en particulier en lien avec
le texte que nous étudions actuellement
sur l'immigration je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur
Darmanin monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous le savez dans votre
département des Hautes Alpes ainsi que
dans les Alpes Maritimes nous avons
expérimenté à la demande du Président de
la République une nouvelle façon de
tenir la la frontière avec des
renforcements de moyens très importants
et un commandement unique pour
l'ensemble des forces de tous les
ministères qui contribuent à la
protection de cette frontière et c'est
efficace très efficace puisqu'on a
augmenté de 70 % depuis le début de
cette expérimentation 1er juillet les
nonadmissions les retours dans les pays
d'origine et également vous le savez
plus de 60000 refus d'entrée prononcés
depuis le début de l'année alors
évidemment le Conseil d'État ayant saisi
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
sur la question préjudicielle que vous
évoquez doit interpréter désormais la
décision de la Cour de justice qui
cependant je voudrais le dire ici parce
que j'ai lu parfois l'inverse mais c'est
pas ce que vous avez dit permet aux
États européens de rétablir des
contrôles de frontières intérieures ce
que nous faisons depuis 2015 et ce que
nous renouvelons en vue d'un évidemment
de menaces terroristes très forte
surtout l'année 2024 qui sera l'année
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques il
y a donc possibilité d'avoir des cont
contrôles de frontières intérieur
c'était l'objet de la question
préjudicielle puisque le Conseil d'État
avait été saisi par plusieurs
associations militantes et désormais ce
conseil l'État doit nous dire comment on
doit mettre en place cette retenue qui
permet aux gens de repartir spontanément
en effet dans le pays pour lequel ils
ont traversé une frontière en
l'occurrence l'Italie pour ce qui vous
concerne nous pensonsnous qu'il y a une
possibilité que le Conseil d'État nous
décrive la l'action d'une police qui
n'est pas engossée dans plusieurs
procédures administratives ou
judiciaires qui relèverait plutôt de la
garde à vue ce qui serait sans doute une
lecture un peu restrictive de la
décision de la Cour de justice mais nous
pourrions et ce travail que fait
ministère de l'Intérieur convaincre nous
les on le conseil de l'État le Conseil
d'État qui va pouvoir nous dire comment
ces policiers ces gendarmes peuvent
travailler et nous pensons que le droit
européen sera tout à fait compatible
avec ce que nous faisons notamment dans
le cadre de l'expérimentation du 1er
juillet c'est-à-dire un travail en
commun de tous les actions
ministérielles et donc d'un refus une
nonadmission aussi rapide soit-il
lorsque quelqu'un traverse
irrégulièrement le territoire national
donc j'ai confiance dans la décision du
Conseil d'État oui nous pouvons faire
des contrôles intérieurs oui nous
pouvons faire des nonadmissions espérons
qu'on pourra le faire dans la meilleure
simplification possible pour les
policiers
arneud merci monsieur le ministre nous
attendons donc la décision du Conseil
d'État je me permets de d'appeler votre
attention sur deux points sur la
frontière italienne dans mon département
la première c'est la nécessité
d'accompagner dignement les personnes
migrantes arrivant à la frontière
actuellement ell sont accueillies dans
des bengalo à 1850 m d'altitude et
d'autre part renforcé de manière durable
avec un escadron de gendarmerie
permanent à la frontière dans la partie
centrale de la frontière italienne avec
la France nécessaire pour pouvoir
garantir l'effort et l'efficacité de nos
services
merci nous avons terminé avec les
question au gouvernement merci madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres no prochaines question
d'actualité auront lieu le mercredi 15
novembre à 15h la séance va être
suspendue elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
des désignations suivie de la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
la séance est
suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur Public
Sénat place à présent au débrief un
débrief qui va être un peu écourté cet
après-midi car d'ici un quart d'heure on
va reprendre la direction de la séance
pour suivre l'examen du projet de loi
immigration un texte que c'est
d'ailleurs invité dans cette séance de
question au gouvernement Audray
notamment à travers